19 pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet you electronically
this is a public hearing on senate bill
on senate bills referred to this
committee with the potential for
executive sessions to be held throughout
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public
groups or
administration contemporaneously
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of this committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries and listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar
on the general core website
the notice of this meeting comprised of
house rules and rsa
91-8
anyone has a problem accessing this
meeting should call 271 360
but student 271-3600
or email hcs
in the event the publix is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i will introduce the staff
that are on the meeting assisting us
brad grieben who's the committee
please researcher that all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by a roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of penance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required on
the right to know
and just remember to understand our
court is not present today so
i'll remain representative in advance
we will be acting as the part for the
um
then
yes good morning i'm present and i am in
my home office alone
and representative martin you're right
nice to meet us in the pledge of
allegiance
just
chairman
uh before we open if you don't mind um i
see we do have some guests online if you
want to explain
you know like if we do any exact or you
know that they have to be on
you know the rules of the video
so
when it comes the question the matter is
puts a question at that point in time
because a member is not in their seat
according to rule 107 that member is not
permitted to vote
for the members participating remotely
your device
the camera has to be on
in order when you're executing so if the
tim is not on
when the matter is put discretion you
will be considered to not be in your
seat
i i would say for the plane of
transparency involved in an executive
session i would
recommend that all members
just didn't really keep their devices
the cameras on at that time
so that that's a strict rule and it
would be strictly enforced
and it has been um
the other the other rule that i would
just emphasize before we begin if
someone wishes to to ask a question of
uh
someone testifying
you're not committed to debate the
witness
you're also not recognized to make a
statement if the member is recognized to
ask a question i expect it to be a
question if a statement is made and not
a question i will
i assume you don't understand that so i
this time
we opened the public hearing
on senate bill
relative to the procedure for conducting
the chair now recognize uh saying that
certainly guided introduce senate bill
141.
thank you mr chairman and distinguished
members of the criminal justice and
public safety committee for the record i
am state senator bob gaida i reside in
warren i represent 27 communities in
district 2 of the new hampshire senate
i am the prime sponsor of senate bill
a bill would authorize the fbi to
conduct all criminal background checks
for all firearms purchases in the state
as opposed to the current system whereby
long guns are in fact uh directly
uh nix checked through the fbi but any
handgun is checked through the state
police gun line
historically the state police gun line
was established
as an interim measure
to
enable the
uh establishment of the mix system uh
pursuant to the brady uh brady act
and
uh and
was never intended to be
a permanent fixture
in the regulation
of the rights
uh to purchase own and carry firearms
however it has in fact
transformed over the years into a
permanent fixture
uh the purpose of this bill
get rid of a system that is costing
taxpayers extra dollars and i can speak
to that a little bit more later
that duplicates the fbi nick system
and is unnecessary
and which in fact has failed on numerous
occasions and in fact resulted in
injuries by firearms to law enforcement
this is
a system
which
currently
this is a system which currently uh
operates in fact without statutory
authority or agency rule
when one reads rsa
one finds that the gun line is only
authorized to perform knicks checks
over the years
the agency has in fact the gun line has
we'll speak to that a little bit more
later
this bill has
very strong support
throughout the state uh
the uh there will be testimony later on
from
uh uh firearms store uh owners
uh and others uh who will
share with you
uh their stories uh and the inordinate
delays that have taken place over the
years
as well the fact that when when the
problem arises because of these
inordinate delays
the gun line responds and then a while
later it falls back into its own ways
the old ways and those delays
are an infringement on the second
amendment uh there are delays both in
the purchasing of firearms initially and
in the restoration of those firearms to
individuals from whom they have been
confiscated
under domestic violence or stalking
orders
i'm in receipt of
a document which i believe each of you
received from the combined offices of
doj and safety yesterday afternoon
that document is an affirmation
of the activities of the gun line
in testimony before the senate
stated
that
without
authority the gun line continues to
operate and
that the gun line in fact exists in
large part
because the court system
maintains a hundred and seventy thousand
name database 170 000 records
that are inaccurate and have never been
disposed of and never received the
proper disposition
so the gun line is actually in in fact
covering for the ineptitude of the court
system
to police its own records that in and of
itself should be concerning
the gun line removes uh gets removed and
in place we we
replace the sheriffs
uh as
the performers of background checks
with respect to
the court ordered interactions with uh
gun owners for example domestic violence
or stalking orders when guns are seized
and uh the bill provides funding for the
sheriff for six months
uh and a six-month gap between that
funding and the actual
disestablishment of the state police gun
line to enable any administrative
operational technical
the
sheriffs have had concerns as as have
local police we have addressed those
concerns with amendments to the original
bill and those amendments are contained
in the version that you have
[Music]
that's the current amended version from
the senate
so
the system
will allow in fact will require the
courts instead of submitting domestic
violence orders and releases there from
and stalking orders and releases there
from
to
uh the gun line
uh they will be directly sent
to
the gun line for
forwarding to the nix system so that
they're in the next system very rapidly
currently there are delays in those
records being forwarded which of course
those who are the subject of those
protective orders
so what we do is we make the system much
more streamlined
much less expensive
and much more in line with the
constitutional freedoms we do away with
a system that is not authorized by
statute or rule to operate currently in
state government
and in so doing
we cause no harm we increase no danger
to those who may be threatened
we do in fact do a great service for
those who practice the second amendment
within our state
we'll speak for just a moment to costs
uh in this year's budget uh the
uh department has added two positions
uh costing roughly two hundred thousand
dollars a year
to the gun line
in addition they pulled eight troopers
off the line to deal with a backlog at a
cost of in excess of two hundred
thousand dollars in the in this this
present fiscal year
uh and and again
i reiterate that the system
uh is not even authorized to operate as
it is under law it is only authorized
under 159 to perform the next checks as
a point of contact defined under federal
law
and so without further further ado i'm
going to go ahead and accept any
questions mr chairman and thank you for
thank you sir for your testimony
[Music]
representative true you're recognized
for a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
so is that the cost of the my question
is is is the 400 000 the annual cost of
i'm sorry could you repeat the question
cost of uh 200 000
personnel
yeah the state troopers was it was a
one-time cost
uh brought they were brought in to
uh to do the background checks that
weren't being done to catch up on this
huge backlog
and um i am fairly certain that they may
have been released back to their
original posts
but the department will probably uh
convert it can uh you know testify to
that effect the two hundred thousand
dollars a year will of course go up
paying benefits for two full-time clerks
as well as those there currently uh and
here we grow government uh not
authorized by statute or a rule
uh in a system that has done background
checks that are not authorized and far
exceed uh any authorization under the
nyx system
uh we repair
uh the
um
i should say we improve the
delivery of
court-ordered records uh protective
orders
to the unix system so that it is
basically instantly available within 24
hours
for checking by anyone that might do a
background check as an ffl
um a federal firearms licensed dealer in
the state and so
again we we make the system much more
efficient much less expensive and much
more
in line with the constitutional rights
under uh under ours and the federal
constitutions
representative recognized for a
follow-up question thank you mr chair
and thank you again
i'm just trying to get a feel for the
you're looking at
uh 200 000 a year
for
the
state police clerks i'm not certain if
any other personnel would be
uh eliminated from their positions uh in
that particular agency
uh that's a possibility
we do look at the possibility of um
cost to the sheriff's department but as
i said we've provided ten thousand
dollars to each of the ten sheriff's
departments initially for startup costs
in terms of equipment uh the portals to
the fbi training for their personnel uh
and in the six-month uh after that we
will find out
uh exactly what other costs may be
coming along uh again the total number
of checks that the sheriffs would do
right now is between 450 and 500 a year
that's across all counties
uh and so there may be an you know an
adjustment of funding if necessary
but the time taken to do these next
checks
is very very short
under the federal system and so i'm not
certain that there would be any cost
from the sheriff's but we'll adjust to
representatives did you have your hand
up
yes
thank you mr chairman
uh senator
i was curious to why you put it in the
sheriff's hands
thank you for the question
representative and it's good to see you
thank you
uh the sheriffs are located
at the court system basically all right
and um
and for that reason
in terms of efficiencies
when the court makes an adjudication the
sheriffs are on scene basically
instantly once they get the record from
the court and they can go to work to
process whatever it is that needs to be
done
thank you uh senator is this going to
bring
any extra
taxpayer money
from the counties
that take care of the shares
no uh no this should not bring any
taxpayer money from the from the
counties uh
it should not cost the counties any
money that's the way i should put it and
uh as i said we'll we'll figure out
exactly what the time and uh you know
cost constraints uh or cost may be and i
believe that the state would
um certainly
cover that cost because it's part of our
representative memes you recognize for a
question yes
thank you and thank you senator for
taking my question
um
one of the things that i'm curious about
is that as i read the bill it doesn't
look like the role of the department of
safety is completely eliminated
so in the case of domestic
violence protection orders uh they
appear to have a role if the county if
county officials can't uh or the county
sheriff will take longer than 24 hours
to actually transmit domestic violence
protection order information into the
system
uh and it also says that uh
yeah so
so the
bottom line is there are several uh
areas uh within the bill
where the role of the state police and
the department of safety appear to be
preserved so i guess my question is is
uh are we really eliminating all of
these costs and and what exactly
is getting eliminated and why the
decision to let some things
remain with the department of safety but
to take other things away before before
this hearing it gets
it's out of hand representing the news
one question at a time for witness
you'll be recognized for a follow-up
question
so just to make sure there's nothing
just there's three questions asked
in that
question so just make sure the witness
that understands the questions let's
keep it
thank you i'm going to try to address
them as i remember them um
the first question yes there is a rule
for the state police
uh and it is uh
to
[Music]
take the domestic violence orders
okay and insert them into nics
um
if the court has not and there will
again i think there'll be personnel that
follow on that have a better
understanding of that process because uh
the
intricacies of it
uh are substantial at present but right
now the state police would be recipients
of domestic orders and and put them into
uh the state plea and into the nick
representative
i'm i'm just curious why that would even
be necessary if the county officials are
are you know are doing what they're
supposed to be doing under the way that
the bill is written um why do you need
the state police to serve as a backup
um
i wouldn't know
i wouldn't need it uh i would say that
you know if you think there's a way that
we can eliminate that i'm certainly
amenable to that
um
i think
again it would provide a central
database
for all domestic violence
and orders
in the state
and we don't have that at present it
certainly would not be the intent of
this bill to allow them to pursue any
other investigative capacity but it
would serve as a repository for all
domestic and stalking orders in the
state
my understanding is that that doesn't
currently exist that they're
and i could be wrong but i think they're
maintained at the respective county
levels
so that would be one benefit of that but
i'll let
subsequent testimony address that issue
representative also you're recognized
good morning thank you mr chairman
thank you senator for taking my question
so i'm actually on page one of your bill
and my i am
i'm i'm looking at
line eight in under findings
and my question is
you have um in your
preamble here
on part two the gun lines inefficiencies
have created significant delays
and i'm curious and could you please
define what that means what is a
significant delay
um and why that how that made it into
the writing of this bill and is
you know is that the problem this bill
is solving
thank you representative for your
question um
that was the net that was the origin of
the request from many people to to to
write this legislation
uh
there were
many times where the initial purchase
would wait days
uh which in and of itself creates a
threat and i think further testimony by
subsequent uh witnesses will will attest
to this
um
but it created really inordinate delays
in the domestic violence and stalking
order return of weapons as long as a
year
people would put in the required
paperwork and would take as much as a
year
i'm led to believe uh that that
the improvements instituted by the
department subsequent to the
introduction of this legislation
has significantly reduced those times
again though at additional cost and and
beyond the scope of any statute or rule
may follow up mr chair representative
you're recognized for a follow-up
question
thank you very much mr chair um thank
you senator guida um
i appreciate
your response to the last question and
now i want to switch gears a little bit
and i'm going to line 22 on page 1 which
i believe
um
references
close to the
references the fiscal note um
on page five
so on line 22 it says this bill saves
tax dollars
and um
from the outset from where i'm sitting
and i've and i'm actually
interestingly enough just got my
rockingham county budget
uh in my hand it arrived the other day
and
after having read this
legislation it appears and perhaps you
can correct me
as to how i'm maybe not understanding
your intent
but it looks like
it looks like
the downshifting of this responsibility
out of the department of safety
responsibility down to the sheriff's
departments which would then be county
responsibilities
is this a question or is there a
question coming
yes sir
so in your
testimony to i believe
um representative muse
you um you had said that there may
or may not be more money
for
counties coming out of the state budget
and
have the
county sheriff's embraced this
downshifting of responsibility to the
county
is it is there a question from him you
just asked i just asked that question
okay so
as to the downshifting as i said that we
have an initial um
outlay of ten thousand dollars per
county
to get the system up and running and any
administrative costs related there to
personnel training and so forth
uh subsequent costs i have i have told
the sheriffs that i will pursue and i'm
sure that the state
will
fund
any additional costs
bearing in mind that
uh
the the costs
of doing a knicks check
are negligible in terms of time
it might take three minutes four minutes
and even if you equate that uh you know
those are costs that are that are
manageable
so
any cost downshifting to the sheriff's
will be funded by the state
uh as i think they must uh it's a state
court system that makes these
adjudications that require this
work by the sheriffs
and so for that reason
i believe the state has the obligation
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
currently
all long guns go through nicks from the
dealer
and all
handguns
go through the new hampshire state
police
but can you also explain
that bottom line the new hampshire state
police
goes to nix
so they're more or less a middleman
is that a question yeah
yeah the system is such
the next system allows the establishment
of point of contact the point of
conquest is law enforcement agency
that's authorized to conduct the mix
checks okay as an interim as an
interface
many states are purely
directly from the purchase point two
nicks some states have points of contact
and in our state statute you find that
the point of contact legislation i'm
sorry a law in the 159
only authorizes the department to use to
do nix checks all right and they that
next system queries three different
background uh three different databases
for
uh potential violations that would
disqualify a purchaser so
uh yeah uh the
the state police do the next check and
and then they do other checks that are
not authorized in statute in fact they'd
really gotten out of line uh and and
were out in fact going back to states of
residence and states of birth of people
way outside the scope of anything that's
that's uh rational
uh and so
that's another reason that we decided to
put this legislation in
uh to
bring them into conformity with the
existing law that only authorizes the
follow-up
representative
for a follow-up question thank you mr
chairman
uh senator
bottom line
can new hampshire let's say knicks got
shut down
can new hampshire do their own
background checks without knicks
the answer is a categoric no
in fact in the legislation currently
under consideration at the federal
congress uh there's an extension up to
ten days
uh uh before um you know of a delay
uh it had been suggested by some that
that doesn't apply to the state police
gun line that's categorically false the
state police gun line as a point of
contact is subject to exactly the same
rules and regulations and delays as a
firearms dealer so
there's no special category no special
lines no special anything they are
subject to exactly the same laws and
that's not me that's the congressional
research service that compined on that
legislation
thank you senator for your testimony the
chair would like to inquire um
or ask a question and i want to thank
you in advance for taking my question
can you describe uh in your opinion at
least what is causing some of these
delays because in my opinion
like i i never i never experienced it so
i i've heard the story what what is
causing these delays
uh i would suggest that um
in one case uh
well in numerous cases
uh the large
volume of checks that needed to be done
uh i think certainly
uh the
outreach by the department into areas
not authorized by statute or rule
in checking things um and a a large part
of that is the
uh again the 170 000 uh records that
have not been uh apprecia achieved
disposition by the department of justice
uh so again a little house cleaning
wouldn't hurt there
and so
uh
volume of sales
the overreach by the department beyond
its statutory uh authority um and
personnel shortage i think uh are are
thank you
representatives
for a question
[Music]
thank you senator for taking my question
i'm just wondering
how many people will be needed to be
hired at the sheriff's department to
uh my answer to that would be none the
volume of of of cases that they would
deal with i said is is 450 roughly a
year
uh that from the uh justice departments
uh uh own the numbers
uh and
if you if you look at that if you
divided it out either on the basis of
population or otherwise
to do the next check or the research
might take an hour it can be done by
anyone that's authorized by law to do
those checks it could be someone that's
required to be deputized it could be a
dispatcher at 11 o'clock at night
so
there should be no additional personnel
requirements the system is very quick
the system is very easy to use it's a
direct portal into the next system and
uh very simple to operate we will of
course pay for the training of the
individuals that will operate it
thank you
representative recognized for a question
thank you uh mr chair and thank you
senator for taking my question
um could you just elaborate on my
understanding is that the handguns
use the uh
the fbi nisk is that correct and then we
use the gun line for long guns
uh
no sir i think that's in reverse the a
person that purchases a long gun
uh the ffl the dealer directly queries
the next system
but the state police gun line is only
for handguns
and uh and that again uh
it begs the question
if a person wanted to do harm
it was not authorized to buy a handgun
because of the checks done by the state
police they would still be authorized to
purchase a long gun
and so that begs the question are we
really doing anything for the safety of
individuals with this if we made it
through the fbi directly and submitted
all the court orders and so forth there
both long guns and handguns as in many
other states
would trigger the um
the disqualifier
and the administrative process much
quicker
the same information in there much more
quickly
and again to the benefit of both the
consumers and of course the dealers and
i think the safety of the people of the
state
follow-up
representative recognized for a
follow-up question
thank you very much
so
um
just for further elaboration why don't
we just use the nist system for both
that's exactly what we're trying to do
here sir
okay
representative i'll show you recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for indulging me in another question
um i'm you mentioned in your testimony
that the state is conducting through the
gun line 450
to 500 inquiries per year
um and so we know that that can't
possibly um
shake out to the to the counties in with
an equal distribution do you have
information as to which counties receive
more and what the how many what um the
inquiries are per county
all right look thank you for the
question representative um
i need to clarify that
the domestic the court
the court involved
um
cases are 450 500 a year obviously many
more total across the state in terms of
purchases of firearms overall
and so um it's it's it's as a sure bet
that it's not a linear distribution it's
not equally against the counties and so
um but it's also uh
again counties generally have more staff
if they're bigger and more population
uh and again the amount of time to
conduct these checks within the confines
of current statute
uh is very limited it's very minimal
and
that would um
again
i don't think it would certainly exceed
anything that the state
follow-up mr chair
are you recognized for our follow-up
question
thank you very much and thank you for
the
for taking this follow-up question so
um i'm going to ask this through the
lens of somebody who lives in one of the
more populated counties here in the
state i live in rockingham county
and it would seem that based on
population
um
that
if
that my county and perhaps
merrimack county another very populated
county would um
perhaps be processing or be their
sheriff's department might have to
process a whole lot more
of these requ of
these checks than say a less populated
county
and so that distribution of funding
that's in the bill in part
lines 21-26
it looks like the distribution is is
equal but
um there seemed there is there isn't
anything in that space and
would you consider
putting into that space
a
state um
commitment
to covering that cost rather than
making these
counties come back to the state on an
annual basis or i'm sorry bi-annual
basis for the biennial budget so that
those costs don't shift down
to the counties because right now it
looks like
once the training is over if i read this
correctly once this training is over
and
uh setup is done on lines 21 22 and 23
then all state money seems to go away
so
would there would you be interested in
adding in
a state budget
for this
so that counties can
meet that demand
i would certainly entertain that
representative it's an excellent
question
again that ten thousand per county is is
the initial
training equipping and so forth and uh
the bill does not address beyond that
i'd be happy to do so
i think it'd be important uh to reassure
uh counties um again it may need
adjustment
um i'm not sure we come up with a figure
and that was one of the reasons we
wanted to have that six-month window
between getting the funding to set the
system up and actually switching over to
it to try to figure out um exactly what
those costs would be and then to bring
them in and i'd be happy to entertain
language to do that i certainly think
it's the state's obligation
the last follow-up question
thank you um and thank you for taking uh
my last question so uh if i if you turn
just so the other members of the
committee know where i am i am on page
five
on the fiscal note and there's
other than the money that's laid out on
page four as
um
startup costs
which are equitably distributed through
the counties
there's um there's nothing in the fiscal
note and i'm concerned and
i think
one other thing that's uh
did you mean to do this
um was
there's no projection of how how much
can how many how much staff
would need to
be instituted by county to make this
work and also support
systems throughout those six months or
is the support supposed to be in that 10
grand
yeah
i think i know what the question is but
let me uh
the 10 000 is is basically the cost of
setting up the system in each of the
counties
okay
and and that includes
computer terminal if necessary
um i don't believe the fbi charges for
access to the portal it'd be a secure
portal and the training required to to
as to how to use the next system
and so
um
that 10 000 is in the bill
i'm not sure
it does it does in fact if you read at
the bottom it abolishes the state police
gun line
again i'm not sure where your what the
exact um
metrics of your question are
but it would save
uh considerable amount of money
and uh as well as the the the the
the two additional
staff that we're going to be added in
this year's budget at a tune of about
180 000
so you're going to save close to half a
million dollars a year
that money
i'm sure would more than cover the cost
to all the sheriff's departments
uh remember given that they're going to
be doing the knicks checks
uh and they'll be they'll be researching
the domestic violence orders which will
now be directed
straight into nix and also to the
department of safety uh and referencing
representative muse's question of course
uh that may uh even further streamline
the process but i think further
testimony subsequent to mine will more
more appropriately address those
almost
[Music]
to ask
questions thank you chairman um thank
you senator for taking my question
so this completely i might understand
this basically bypasses the fbi need for
us to to use them and we handle
no what
thank you for the question
there is not it is not lawfully possible
to
bypass the fbi
uh nyx system
for the purchase of any firearm in the
country
um
what this bill does is it takes the from
the state police gun line
okay
the processing of checks into domestic
violence and stalking orders
gives that to the sheriffs because
they're co-located with the courts
and and
it then
directs the court system
to directly input
to the fbi uh parenthetically we have
checked the fbi is capable and ready to
to accept those records any domestic
violence or stalking orders into the
next system
all right so we stop any delays at the
state police and we we go direct from
the court straight into knicks the
sheriff's
when these court orders regarding
domestic violence and and stalking are
rescinded or
then the sheriff goes into nix looks and
sees it's been rescinded because without
that
that creates the delay uh that's been
prevalent in the state police records uh
through the gun line so
um again
it actually streamlines the process and
requires and provides the next system
with the information it needs
but that it's not currently getting
because it's going to the state police
represent finance
yes thank you chair thank you senator um
so it's getting a little clearer so
um
we want people to be able to protect
ourselves themselves and i agree with
that so this streamlines the process for
less waiting periods do you have any
data on how many incidents there were
for people that actually waited before
this was enacted as our current law
exists is there any incidents that come
to mind this is the reason why we need
to put this bill forth you have any
data on that any numbers of what's going
on in the state
i think subsequent testimony will
provide that but i can tell you it's in
the hundreds if not the thousands of
delays that have been encroached caused
over over the last several years i'm
sorry to interrupt i don't mean delays i
mean victims that have fallen prey
because of a delay do you have any
incidents
where there was a crime because of this
i can specify i i know of one specific
one that was two manchester police
officers that were shot not too long ago
by a person who escaped if you will the
scrutiny of the state police gun line
i think subsequent testimony will attest
you know two
more specific incidents
um that have happened uh again of
concern uh is the situation where
because of the delay
the
uh the individual
can can procure a weapon after three
days under federal law
and
you know that particular weapon for
which they applied for the the uh the
knicks check
it puts the gun dealers in a terrible
position
and so
again
if we take the gun line away we leave
the sheriff's there to deal with the
domestic violence piece and all firearms
purchases go directly to knicks
we stop a lot of these delays that were
caused with the short stop at this at
the gun line before things got down
to the fbi before the weapon was
chair witness representative o'hara for
a question
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question and i may have a
follow-up but my first question is you
stated that
the sheriff's department
is at the courts and that
they would work hand-in-hand
together but it is my understanding that
the sheriff's departments are only at
the superior court level and
on the circuit court level
the bailiffs are through the other um
security system uh through the state so
i see
a potential problem with that
well i don't i would i would offer that
uh if the court puts the records into
the nick system
all right
electronically immediately upon the
issuance within 24 hours of the issuance
of the
domestic violence or uh or stalking
order
that information is available to the
sheriff's wherever they're located
all right so
i'm not sure that the geographic
location together
uh with the courts is is really a factor
here but the point being that the courts
would directly input the stuff into the
mix
and it would be instantly accessible to
any
ffl dealer to the sheriff's to anybody
that was then to queer the system
so
in the beginning of this uh your
statement or if i recall you said that
you know that the state police don't
have the authority and that this is
going to
clean it up so that we downshift it to
the sheriff's but wouldn't have been
much easier to just propose something
that
corrects the problem
on the state level instead of
i think for the sake of efficiency
uh you know the gun line is is going to
cause costs already it's half a million
a year
um
and
i i just think that things are handled
better locally close to the courts
um
and
again as to the downshifting
uh the term again we're covering the
costs of implementation
we have six months to study uh
what other costs might be uh in
incurred over the operational lifetime
and once we get into the using the
system at the uh at the sheriff's level
and those costs as i've said i'm more
than happy to entertain an amendment uh
as suggested by representative
aldshiller
uh to address those issues going forward
we're trying to get a handle on if those
costs would exist and what they would be
and that's that's another reason for
greene
do you recognize her question yes thank
you mr chair
refresh thank you senator for taking my
question
uh
several years back there was a gun
dealer on 125 in
he was a single person in the store
three gentlemen came in to purchase a
handgun
they did the background check through
the same police
and the guys were getting very impatient
about about 25 30 minutes later
three state police showed up three state
cruisers showed up
and arrested these guys there was a
warrant out for them
and when they were being arrested they
threatened the gun dealer
and
two weeks later the gun dealer opposed
the shot and that was it
did you believe that
by going with the knicks is this gonna
i absolutely do
absolutely do um
and i think it would be better uh again
for the reason stated would be much
streamlined
uh and if a knicks alert goes out
the next alert goes out the state police
should be notified um
i think uh potentially
uh and and respond as quickly you know i
okay thank you for taking my question
representative means you recognized for
a question
thank you for taking another
question from me senator
um
one of the things that's baked into the
bill is the assumption that the courts
can directly input
domestic violence protection order
information
my understanding from some bills that we
heard testimony on uh uh in the last
session uh is that uh the state actually
provides and submits protection order
information into a different database
than nics so
it's actually submitted into the
national crime information center ncic
database uh through spots the state
police online telecommunications system
my question is is if this if the state
police are not involved in this process
uh and this is something the courts are
going to be doing directly
would the courts have access to a system
like that and and how would this work
the next system checks three things uh
and one's triple i i forget the second
and the third is ncic that you mentioned
um
again that's that's more of an
electronics question
uh
as to which database the court's
documents go into
as long as they're submitted directly
and timely
the next system will check that database
i said ncic is one of them that is
checked a national crime information
center
and so i don't think that's a problem i
think it's a matter of electronics as to
which
database the information it's currently
going from the state police there if we
take the state police out
we just send it directly there from the
court system
representative you recognized for a
final question
um
my follow-up question would be is if
that's something that doesn't exist now
isn't that the kind of thing that would
actually add to the implementation cost
of a system like this and and given the
level of security that would be
necessary for something like that
wouldn't that be a
fairly significant cost i don't think so
i think it's a computer terminal
uh the the portal into whichever system
it is the uh i think might be triple i
whichever ncic
um
i don't see a cost there that's any of
any substantial nature
i said we're already doing it through
the state police it's just a matter of
switching the recipient
instead of sending the information to
the state police to send in we send it
directly to that very database
mr chairman members of the committee i
appreciate your consideration of this
[Music]
we're going to limit testimony to three
minutes for witness also
we've been following this
throughout the hearings that each member
is limited to two questions per per
witness i did allow an exception for
obviously the
senator who introduced the bill and i
invited an exception for the question as
well but claim forward that we're going
well mr chairman should i uh make a
point of order
you don't have to ask to make a point of
order all right one more
one of what it is thank you mr chairman
um
you know uh on this particular topic we
got two and a half hours
to have a debate and i see some hands up
you know to speak
i would just hate to limit three minutes
when key people chime in
because they're gonna have a lot of good
information
and then to limit us just the two
questions
you know it is discretionary my
understanding is that it's the both the
restriction on the amount of questions
and the time limit
for witnesses
uh it's within the discretion of the
chair
uh
for the people who've been following
along often see that
i would be allowed 10 seconds 15 seconds
leeway with that
and it's at the discretion chair at one
point with anything that witnessed one
minute and i did allow it to go on for
seven minutes given the
the weight is
subject matter for testimonials that was
in a different hearing
it is within the scratching the chair so
i'm not i understand your point of order
keep keep the hearing going on the
library this is present we have uh
people who work for the state that are
present remember the public presence
we want to make sure that people want to
pay schedules actually able to testify
if we have additional time
take that consideration as well
[Music]
that there's a new fiscal note for the
bill that
is apparently inside our email that was
sent to us at 9 30 to 9 32 this morning
green
who sent it the committee researchers
okay
at this time the chair uh recognizes
good morning mr chair can you hear me
yes commissioner
yes um thank you uh good morning
everyone i just wanted to um clarify my
name is robert quinn i am the
commissioner of the department of safety
president my office
is also lieutenant michael mcquaid
who oversees the permits and licensing
unit currently referred to as the gun
line um as you've heard in uh prior
testimony we have been addressing
a rather large increase
in
requests for purchases we have done
quite a bit over the last several months
i also wanted to say we have partnered
with the courts and i believe um
attorney richard head is also on the
line our permits and licensing unit have
worked closely with the courts um as you
you know heard prior testimony we've um
heard um about protective orders and
domestic violence orders
some orders that are can be entered into
ncic some orders that cannot
you've heard about different systems
here
federal systems state systems databases
where this is such an important issue
and a rather complicated issue
we provided and i know the courts
provided a fact sheet
and i just wanted to ask the chair um
does the to sir do you and the members
of the committee have you received what
was
the work that was done by the courts and
representative abbas i just wanted to
we do have members participating
remotely have have the materials his
email to us yesterday
okay thank you and i don't i don't want
to speak for attorney head i know he's
he's um he's also present on the call um
i just um what i wanted to do was ensure
that
and i think that this work product
clearly outlays out the background
the differences between
the search that's conducted by the fbi
and the permits and licensing unit
also addresses the return of the
firearms which has been discussed
earlier and the process and the
difference in the process
and what we have done to
streamline or improve the efficiency
and
that is we've redefined the scope of the
checks and we've aligned it more but i
think it's important to understand um
the difference between
the databases so that everybody is clear
what is nix what is ncic what is
contained in the nix index and what does
the permits and licensing unit do and
currently the permits and licensing unit
also includes the licensure of security
guards uh explosives and private
investigators so this permits and
licensing unit where the gun line duties
exist have other collateral duties but
i would uh i again i don't want to go
through this line by line but i think
it's important for the committee to make
sure that
everybody understands clearly what the
differences is and how some of these
protective orders may be
entered into ncic or may not
and those that are not rest solely in
the permits and licensing unit for
aquarium cross-check
so
uh i would uh again for for for time i
would like to uh again i've got
lieutenant mcquaid here and i would like
the courts to be able to speak more
specifically to their process and how
the protective orders travel from you
know uh
from from a victim to the courts you
know what gets entered into ncic and and
and what doesn't and again just as a
little history which is contained in it
we've been conducting handling this at
the department of safety since uh 1993.
so
representative abbas i would um avail
myself to any questions on any of the
content that is contained within this uh
eight-page document and i want to thank
attorney head for partnering up with uh
lieutenant mcquade and uh
and putting this together so um i i open
to any questions that you may have and
again i'm i'm joined by lieutenant
mcquaid who might step in as well thank
you sir
thank you commissioner for your
testimony and the chair would uh require
a question of the witness i want to
thank you in advance for taking my
question
i if you know testimony from the from
the senator who introduced the bill
he spoke about
these
a series of delays that people were
having
that were um
laying the process um do you have any
uh
explanation for what is causing the
delays
oh absolutely so he is correct there
were delays and i think that we had over
a 60 percent increase in gun sales
that coupled with um during copen we had
some employees that were out
impacted by covet so you had us over 60
approximately 65 percent increase in
volume but more importantly
we had a process
the statute doesn't define exactly what
the check is that is done by the permits
and licensing unit so we work closely
with the attorney general's office and
we redefined the scope what is the check
that the permits and licensing unit will
do
and we were
we redefined it and we brought it back
so we believe it is in the best interest
of of public safety and it was um
you know looking further into our own
criminal records repository to ensure
that there were not disqualifiers that
had not get uploaded into the nix index
but balancing the right of somebody to
purchase a firearm and some of these
delays were you know
were unacceptable so i think what we did
is
we redefined the scope of the check
which i i think was very important we
looked at our
our phone system which we've readdressed
in in the past several months
we've looked at you know the technology
potential for improvements on some of
these databases but i think the key is
we have been able to keep these backlogs
down
um i think they are in a good position
right now we address the backlogs in the
court so to answer your question sir it
was a 60 over 60 60 65 percent increase
in call volume was essentially a perfect
stop and we dealt with some uh vacancies
due to covert but
and also again the scope of the check
it was in my opinion too expansive we
redefined it we're looking at our own
state records
we're looking we're querying against the
list that we get from the aoc daily on
any protective order where the victim
does not have a date of birth we query
that look at our own state and then
align with the fbi the other issue is we
had many cases that were in delay status
and sometimes it can go into delay
because of this an example is somebody
wants to purchase a firearm the permits
and licensing unit
clerk looks at the record the record on
its face
is incomplete there isn't enough
information in there to determine is
there is that a disqualifier is that a
disqualifier what actually happened in
the court what was the final
adjudication
what is the potential sentence so they
have to reach outside of the state they
maybe have to look towards another state
and quite honestly it just we you know
many states just aren't responsive in
time and we're supposed to have these uh
if it's in delayed get it to deny to
approve within three business days so
what we did we had many that were far
beyond the fbi uh limit of i believe
it's 88 days
and so what we did was we brought ours
back after 88 days
if um if we can't get an answer then we
take it out of that delayed status so so
to address
we've looked at our process
we looked at our personnel we looked at
cross training we've looked at our phone
system and we redefine the scope
of our stop
of our background check to ensure that
we balance
we're balancing the right to purchase a
firearm with doing a safe as safe as
reasonable background check
understanding we could not
call all 50 states to ensure that there
is not a
disposition
or a conviction that hasn't been
uploaded and just to be clear for
everybody this is very complicated but
in the triple i database what we refer
to as the fbi check if there is a
conviction in any state where the
defendant was not fingerprinted that
would not be in that database
so um so i hope that answered that
thank you commission thank you again for
taking my question
uh the chair recognizes representative
yes thank you commissioner for taking my
question um
my question is around
any
inconsistencies that you might see as
you look at the bill and as you read it
and the way that you understand that the
process not only is working now
but would have to work um if it's
changed the way that it's specified in
this bill so do you see things that
based on your knowledge of uh the way
the system works the way the fbi works
um
that could be problematic
well i mean
you know
i mean the in simplest terms is this if
you purchase a lawn gun today in new
hampshire it goes to the fbi
and they run it through their next check
that you know we are i believe one of
three states if you purchase a handgun
um if you were to send it to the fbi
to keep it as simple as possible if you
look at our fact check here there are a
couple of there are several
steps that would not be checked that
would be missed
and and i think that that is something
that that is just you know that that
that is accurate we're doing
above and beyond
some steps that that they would do and
i go back to that list of i believe it's
roughly 50 to 70 that
file a protective order for whatever
reason and we get that emailed so
we
cross check against that prior to
approving on a
on any purchase so i would say uh
you know
to the return of firearms
we do the return of firearms with these
that have been taken through the courts
and
sometimes the local police departments
if they seize a weapon whether it's from
a you know a a a burglary or whatever
reason they can they can run that next
check as well to see if the weapon can
be
be returned but again when we do that
process
through the courts we also query against
the list that we're getting that's
unsupported by a date of birth so i
would say representative muse we do uh
we do we do have we have done and we do
more than the fbi we were doing several
additional steps but as i said as our
policy we redefined it we brought it in
because it was just not sustainable and
so we had to balance it so
and again that's contained in this
in this uh in this document in more
detail
thank you mr chairman and thank you
commissioner and the other gentleman
that's with you
i would like to know are you in favor of
this bill or opposed to this bill
we're remaining neutral representative
welch what i mean by that i believe this
is a policy decision and what i've said
is this if the gun line
or if the gun line
is to stay within the department of
safety and the permits and licensing
unit we will do the best we can to
ensure customer service is met public
safety and we do the best job we can if
the decision is made to send this to the
um to the fbi then i believe that's um
that's
you know rests in your hands so we're
remaining neutral on it
representative you recognize for a
follow-up question thank you mr chairman
thank you uh commissioner
i cannot remain neutral i have to take a
vote a vote means i gotta go up or down
and i'm saying to you
[Music]
give me a vote up or down with the bill
or against the bill don't give me
neutral
and affordable
order mr chairman this witness is not an
elected official to vote and give a
decision
to representative marston which he was
let's vote on fine night i believe i've
the representative asked
a question of the witness whether they
oppose a bill or they support a bill the
witness has the right to answer the
question saying that they are mutual
but that being said
uh if you it's quite often that when any
witness testifies before
i believe this is actually the policy of
every committee that the witness states
their position whether it's in support
opposition or neutral so your point of
order was recognized
and that's the ruling of the chair so
the question is appropriate
i also believe that that question was
asked and answered already but if the
commission wishes to clarify he met
representative newman you recognize for
thank you was that for me mr chair
you were a little garbled you were the
only representative on the committee you
were recognized
thank you
and thank you commissioner for taking my
question yes sir this is this is a
complicated issue and there seems to be
that the gun line
um did a lot of
extra things to check the extra
databases that we have information on
and
in your reading of this bill do you see
that
that that
type of ability to do that kind of thing
when it's transmitted to the counties
that
your the experience the gun line has had
with that kind of stuff will go will be
adequately trained to the people at the
uh
uh county level
well i i think here's a here's a point
of clarification
the county level
will not be making these decisions this
will go to the fbi nix
they will make the decision and those
representative also you're recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you
commissioner quinn
you mentioned in your testimony that new
hampshire has seen a 60
increase
in gun sales is that in this past
calendar year or what was the um
time frame that you're referencing there
so we did ma'am and again just
give or take uh several i believe it was
57 000 in 2019
87 000 in 2012
and we are currently in the area of 30
with four months so we we
we estimate an increase um in 21 from
20.
so that was from 19 to 20 which was the
over 60 percent you know approximately
60 63 65 percent increase
those are the years
man follow up mr chair
you're recognized for a follow-up
question thank you very much
uh thank you commissioner
i would appreciate an answer in either
the 2021 range or the 2020 range
whatever information you have
but if the concern
for this bill seems to be that
people are not able to access a purchase
of a firearm and so my question is
uh with this increase in sales how many
of these people are first-time gun
owners
we don't in in and by statute we're not
allowed to retain that information
it's and it's 63 which is these numbers
are on page six six of the uh which the
okay that i don't i don't have that
document that was not sent to me
um so did you i'm sorry 63 increase not
60. did i hear you wrong six yes with
over eight yeah so
so
both in 19 and 20 the gun line realized
significant increases in the number of
queries that were received from the over
400 ffls
throughout the state with over 86 000
checks being processed in 2020 which
represented a 63 increase
we are limiting questions to two to two
yes uh commissioner
would you agree that the gun line
has experienced problems and have those
would yes i would i would agree that the
gun line had
had significant delays
and
we have addressed them
and i believe today
we are in a
better position stable
we're looking at the metrics
times
frequency of calls
staffing
call taking and scope of the checks so
and i would give give the credit to
lieutenant mcquaid and his team and
again we've partnered very closely with
the courts
to ensure that we're
uh there's synergy there between us and
the receipt of information that we need
to make these decisions so yes i i will
you know
absolutely there there were delays but
again i go back to
we had a 63 percent increase in volume
and we're also dealt internally with
you know some issues uh due to covert
but it's in a much
more stable position today and i think
representative
i'm sorry sir could you repeat that
what is your plan for the immediate
future for improving the government sure
thank you for the question well in this
budget we have requested three
additional positions
um the plan is to get these troopers you
know back to what
they uh their jobs which you know we
understand that recognize that and
looking at potential technology
options the phone system
um
the aligning more with the fbi i mean
quite honestly the scope of our search
was too expansive and that really um
i would say increased our our delays so
i think that was probably
the most significant
um
significant step to address the gun line
that hadn't been taken in years and i
credit the attorney general at the time
for working
on that with us so i think we have a
good check
in place we're looking at you know we
know when the shows are we know the
busier time the peak times you know
we're tracking that the metrics and i
think the call you know the call system
being able to put you know taking 400
calls and getting them in a queue as
opposed to you know five so
you know we've really looked close at
the customer service
um and and um
you know and and
process improvement and it's continuous
process improvement sir so
i hope i answered that
representative night you were recognized
for a question
thank you chairman and thank you
commissioner for taking my question
um my question is even with any kind of
delay in processing paperwork doesn't
page two lines eight through ten ensure
anyone
in any county can buy a gun without
any sort of background check and um
i have a follow-up after that if you can
oh oh
i don't have the bill and so are you
talking about the could you just be a
little more specific with what those
lines are because i i don't have that on
my screen i'm i'm looking at our facts
all ten
and if i can just have a minute i'm
trying to get that
yeah no problem take your time and while
[Music]
you may be recognized for a follow-up
question
if we can if i can just get that if we
can go to another question and i'll i'll
try and get that ma'am if it works and
we'll come back to that one
thank you so much my other question is
if that's the case um how will this
relate to the active white supremacist
those out of order
there's a foundation to such questions
there's no restriction on firearm
purchases based on race at all
anywhere in this country that i am aware
of
that pressure's out of order in the
commission you don't need please you do
not have to respond to that question
thank you sir representative
you were recognized for a question thank
you mr chairman thank you commissioner
um
several questions ago you said
and i hope i quote you correctly
nix won't do the background checks as
the lot
so here's the question you know if you
said this this is what i heard
the law is very clear so who is
following the law is it nix or is it the
new hampshire state police on background
checks because only one can do it if
you're saying that nix won't do the
background checks
as
as you guys do
well yeah just no just to clarify it we
do additional checks but we also do
the nics check
so
in our document that we're presented
what we will do is what we will do that
the fbi does not do is look further into
a conviction say a record in new
hampshire to determine if it's a
potential disqualifier for example if a
simple assault had a domestic violence
disqualifying
um
you know factor in it we we do more
representative byrd is what i'm saying
but we also run the knicks yeah the next
check so we do that as well
and when you say the when you say the
law the law says we may be the point of
contact and that's why we worked
internally
for a follow-up question thank you and
thank you for the uh answer you just
gave me
um
also you said which i had the numbers
approximately
purchases of handguns 87 000 to 2020
this is what i'm being told so there is
a question at the end here
i went to a lot of gun stores and
they're telling me that
today they can get a background done
approximately five to ten minutes
if you answer the phone but where the
problem is is that
the new hampshire state police
is not answering the phone to one to
three hours
then they you know they can get in the
gun store can get in to answer that to
answer the uh to do the next
so what happens if
the sales jumps to over a hundred
thousand how are you going to handle
this
so
so that's so so
you act you actually asked two questions
so one is
um
why is it
why is it that at times
you can have
a permits and licensing
employee answer the phone and give you
um
customer service instant approval let's
just say there's no record
and why at times and busier times does
it take time well it's it's you know the
answer is if we've got you know 100
um requests from ffl's in a matter of 10
minutes obviously there's going to be a
delay it's just you know it would be
impossible to have 100 you know
employees answering the phone
so what we've done is looking at um
getting the instant you know customer
service and at least you know having a a
system so that we can and i think the
that ffl's understand that sir to be
honest with you i think they understand
that it can't always be instant i was
asked the question what does that mean
instant well nothing's instant you've
gotta but the process that we are doing
now is we're taking the calls as they
come and trying to give us best service
so
the average wait time is about 14
and again you know it differs at uh you
know on our peak peak times
you may ask one one follow-up question
um
i am not hearing this complaint
on loan guns because it goes to nics
and they have the staff to handle 100 or
a thousand calls in an hour
so you know how are we going to fix this
in new hampshire so that way people are
not waiting hours
sure so
yeah no no no that's a good question and
i think i mean you have to really look
at where we were
where we were
in
april
of last year and where we are today yeah
we were in a hole
you know there's no denying that but we
have made
significant improvements here like i've
spoken to and we continue to build on
that
you know we've got a very scalable
flexible model down there just in the
last two months we've addressed some
phone uh
system delays but again you know as i i
hope you would understand a 63
increase in volume at a time where
you're dealing with uh um you know
employees that could be impacted or out
with covert and once you start getting
that those delays it it it just
continues to add
and the other issue as i stated is we
are sometimes
you know a victim of other states not
being responsive you know when we have
to reach out to get some data so
when we address that 88 days delayed but
we have really cleaned up the backlogs
with the courts and the return of
firearms we've got the customer service
i would say in a much much better place
and if we go from you know uh 87 000
we've already addressed that as we
looked for these new positions in the
budget um and and
and i think with those positions and
potential technology um options out
there we we get this the majority of
folks are approved
okay we have a very small
number that go into delayed um they go
into delayed for the right reasons the
clerks are looking and they're seeing
something that causes it to be delayed
getting it from delayed to approved to
denied we've really uh
i would say um
upped our game there and and it's and
it's this and it was the policy quite
honestly that allowed us to to look and
and define the scope
and and balance the risk
because again calling 50 states
individually to check and see if you
know uh this individual has something in
your state that could be a disqualifier
that isn't in the in the fbi system the
triple i database
is is just not uh it's not reasonable
it's not practical so
it's employees it's technology it's
looking at our phone system
and again the other thing is this uh
representative burke it's it's engaging
our customers more
it's talking to these ffl's and dealing
with them some are small some are busy
at certain times you know working better
with them to ensure that we're giving
them the service they need but i i would
agree with you you know the the the long
gun check is different but again back to
the question that's been asked several
times our check um goes above and beyond
that in several areas which are you know
contained in the in the sheet that i've
included
i i hope that helps sir yes thank you
representing me is your recommend for a
question
yes thank you for
uh for taking my question i i i did have
time to review the uh the sheet that you
sent
and one of the things that i noted that
you note is that there are several
protections that are not included
in sb 141
that look like they would be fairly
significant and important protections um
without me telling taking the time to
tell you what they are
um
could you just review
how important you think those
protections are
sure sure representative news i'm going
to i know that uh the courts have joined
with us and they um are going to also
offer but you know
you know i'll just look at you know the
protective orders of somebody you know
and i've i've been asked the question
hey
why why don't these you know victims
have a date of birth
so that the courts can
put it into ncic
they actually don't put into ncic which
will be caught on a next check and and
the answer is sometimes these are
and i'm not speaking to any particular
case but maybe just the uh the victim
just doesn't know the offender um
by date of birth but wants to file the
protective order and
those would be missed
so i i think that's important and um and
the fact is and i talked to the fbi the
head of the the sieges and i asked would
this list could this list that we get
daily from the courts be entered into
ncic and without a date of birth the
answer i received was no so um and again
they've included the um
child protective act
protection act protective orders but
i'll i'm going to defer to um to the
courts to to speak in a little more
detail on that but i i think they're
important
thank you
representatives are recognized for a
question
thank you mr chairman uh commissioner
thank you for taking my question
uh it seemed as though with this bill
when they addressed it they said all you
have to do is
put it in the computer
and listening to you i find that there's
many other avenues that you have to go
am i correct
the that we are doing the next check
the fbi does the straight next check on
a long gun so if you're comparing a long
gun purchase today to a handgun as i've
said stated we are doing um
some additional steps we're looking
closer at our own database to ensure
that that something on this record is
not a disqualifier and we are also
querying
a list that we received from the
administrative office of the courts
to ensure that somebody um
isn't uh under uh
a protective order or bail conditions
that would uh prohibit them from
purchasing a firearm so we are doing the
next check it's clear i mean and there's
some folks that you know that understand
this and have been dealing in this world
but it it it to keep it in the most
simplest simpler terms is we are doing
additional
checks but not as expansive in the past
which
was um i would say caused you know
increased delays so we're balanced it
in some of those cases
thank
you you're recognized for a question
thank you mr chair thank you
commissioner for taking my question i'm
just trying to clarify something you
just said
uh you just said that if
somebody gets a restraining order they
may not have the birthday
so would that
imply that if bob smith
had a restraining order out on them but
they didn't know what the birth date was
that everybody in the state named bob
smith can't buy a firearm how do you
how do you remedy that
so
the answer to that is we have a
lieutenant that's in charge of the
permits and licensing unit and um that's
a very good question how do they ensure
that the person is not the person and
they can do further checks and and and
inquiries to to make sure they're not um
denying the wrong person so it's with
with further checks the other thing that
hasn't come up either is
sometimes it goes the other way that
white that what might look like a
disqualifier is actually not with
representative representative testimony
for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
these other background checks
that you do
uh i guess the domestic violence ones
are in there
do you keep a record and would it be
disqualifying the person who was
consuming medical marijuana
i did i'm sorry i didn't hear that
do your background checks include
whether or not somebody is
has been prescribed medical marijuana
no
representative tree recognized for a
question
thank you mr chair and uh thank you for
taking the question
um
what does it mean
run it through mix
what is that what is that process when
when something when you say and we and
we run it through next what is that
process sure no that that that's a
that's a that's a great question so if
you look on um
um page two uh i don't know who has it
or who doesn't but the next system
searches
so this search will query against triple
i which is the interstate identification
index
commonly that you'll hear it in in the
police terms is triple i which contains
criminal history
records if a fingerprint was obtained
then you've got in the next index
the
ncic or the national crime information
center which contains records regarding
wanted persons protection orders
deported felons and other matters and
then we talk about the knicks index
the index contains
records regarding all violation
misdemeanor and felony convictions
regardless of fingerprint support which
you disqualify as for federal and state
firearms convictions what i talk about
when
i say that our our unit
checks further into our own database our
own state criminal records
we
know that not all of our convictions
have been uploaded
into nics
so we want to make sure that there
aren't convictions in our own state
we want to get new hampshire
you know where it needs to be before we
make the approval so we're looking
better at our own convictions but we
can't look at 49 other states so
we've got
the nix
system
searches that's the best way to explain
it
but there is a nics index
so within that check that the fbi does
they query against those
um systems that i just explained
and again it's hard to but if you if you
refer back to page two of our handout
you can you can see it in better detail
sir
i don't know who got all my information
i think i filled out a long application
so
do they take my application and fax it
to somebody and
did they introduced by name and social
security number or they look in
my mother's maiden name they're putting
all sorts of information about me into
the check or is it basically just like
my name or social security number maybe
uh
senior for the hands raised i want to
thank you mr chair
china recognizes uh
just a reminder the testimony will be
you can hear me
yes we can
okay
thank you uh mr chairman
and members of the committee
um i think what you just heard from the
commissioner using a lot of words is
the gun line is no longer broke
the problems that you're going to hear
from other people and the stories that
you're going to hear are old stories the
problems have been virtually fixed
there's always room for improvement um
but they've been virtually fixed
um
starting back in december uh the
attorney general mcdonald was engaged in
writing a policy
because it is true that the gun line
needed more direction to know what
checks to do and what checks not to do
so these other state checks have been
eliminated um and that has reduced um
the time that it takes to process
the instant check
process
by far
the department has also added personnel
in the backlogs that we had in the
return of firearms getting firearms back
to innocent people in domestic violence
cases is virtually um on time now the
backlog is gone
we had many cases that were backlogged
well over 88 days
in and nick's policy is if you can't
clear it in 88 days you clear the deck
that is now our policy at the state
level there are no delays beyond 88 days
in new hampshire now
also in this policy um given and the
directives to the gun line is that 90
of all inquiries will be answered
immediately
and that is now the case in fact
less than three percent
of case of inquiries now are delayed
we've changed the way we've handled the
inquiries every inquiry used to come in
and be put in a box and another person
would have to pick up that inquiry do
the check
put in another box in the and the a
third person would call the dealer back
that is gone that system is gone you nee
when you get the phone answered by your
gun line personnel you get your answer
of the time
but that left us with one other problem
which was
um we can't keep up with the incoming
phone calls because of the increase in
volume
for example
many saturdays 400 handguns are sold
that's a lot of checks
so we had to make some mechanical
changes to how we handle the calls and
now
just recently in the last couple of
weeks we have a cued system just like
you hear at some companies that will say
you know your pro you either answer the
call or your approximate wait time is
five minutes or your approximate wait
time is 10 minutes and as you heard the
average wait time is no more than 15
minutes now
so the gun line is no longer broke and
there's still room for improvement
we now have a person in charge of taking
faxes so that the faxes can be answered
right away and not just piled up in a
box and then someone calls them back
when they get around to it
the the department has done yeoman's
work uh in fixing the problems um at the
gun line and they really um
deserve some credit for getting
for getting that uh fixed
i don't see that sending this to the
state sheriffs works
i don't you know they talk about
training people with ten thousand
dollars a piece that's a one-time thing
you go from needing a few people on the
gun line at the state police
you're gonna need to train several
people at each county and retrain people
when they leave when they're out on sick
you know the gun line is a seven day
week operation
and many days 12 13 hours a day i'm not
sure the sheriffs are going to give that
kind of service um
to the guns coming back from the courts
the guns coming you know getting guns
back to innocent people of domestic
violence they're caught up they're doing
their job and we need to let them uh
continue
doing their job so
be happy to answer any questions and i
guess i would also say that the new
hampshire firearms coalition
is in opposition to this bill as written
they would have one suggestion if you
want to take this written policy that
the gun line now has and make it into
administrative rules or make it into law
that they must
um complete all all all checks instantly
or 90 instantly um
then that would be a good idea and they
would support codifying the policy that
was put in place that is virtually
and almost completely corrected the
thank you for your testimony before
questions were asked uh representative
wallace i
would you be able to keep uh being
charged of the timer of which witnesses
testimony
thank you so much
representative you will recognize your
question
thank you mr chairman thank you
executive councilor wheeler for taking
why do you think it is okay to use state
employees
and state tax dollars to fund a federal
mandated program
that the federal government will do for
free
so well thank you for the question
representative burt and i appreciate you
um
uh co-sponsoring the bill here because
if it wasn't for you highlighting the
problem uh maybe it wouldn't have got
fixed so that's that's the good news
here
um
i think that we do a much better job at
new hampshire
and maybe most importantly when there is
a mistaken identity
um in the federal system or when uh you
have
robert smith's
we do a better job at figuring that out
right here in new hampshire
and so far this year i've brought four
cases to the department of safety of the
people that were either
long-time delays or denies and got them
corrected and gotten their firearms back
because you the 424 legislators and the
counselors can walk into that office
across the river and say look we got a
problem here
sometimes it's an old conviction that's
out there 35 years old and people forgot
they had it
sometimes we've had a case where it's
the the feds had wrong information in
the computer and didn't read far enough
when they put the documents in that said
the case was dismissed
and we've corrected those situations and
all 424 of us can get those corrected if
the state remains in the system and that
follow up representative
question thank you mr chairman and thank
you for your um
just last week
saturday i heard that
a young store pretty close to me i was
talking to the person
said that
they spent about two hours trying to
call into the gun line
eventually they answered their phone
so what my question is
have you
experienced
any of these delays you know because how
many guns do you buy through a licensed
dealer so you may experience these
delays
thank you for that question as well
representative burton i tell you what
several of us have been doing out in the
field uh to verify what's going on
inside at the gun line
myself and other people that i know have
taken on three or four gun shops and and
called them regularly and say what do
you see you know what's going on in the
field tell me what the truth is and
these gun shops are telling me two
things one
the system has greatly improved and they
tell us where we need to fix things
and just recently it's just been just
recently that our queued up system has
been added to the gun line so i don't
know how old this this information is
and then we ask these gun shops a final
question
if you had the choice
and if the new hampshire gun line works
well would you rather have the biden
administration in charge of the gun line
or would you rather have
new hampshire
people in charge of the gun line and the
answer is reasonable order i mean like
biden what is this
representative
representative knight
you raised the point of order which you
recommended to raise but all you said
was yeah about fighting what is this
okay my point of order is assuming that
we're putting onus on a presidency
specific
representative
just to clarify
a clean order is appropriate when there
is a challenge to the rules or the
decline being followed
in the committee so please expressly
state which
rule
okay thank you mr chair so should i take
a crack at it
that's your decision
yes i i call point of order because i
think that
um
putting onus on the committee's
responsibility to choose between a
specific president and what we do as a
committee embody for our state is
inappropriate
and thank you i will allow the witness
thank you mr chairman i will rephrase my
or rephrase my answer and i will say
with bills like h.r 1446 um
sitting in congress and already have
passed the house that could change the
rules of how the gun line works
and no one knows for sure how that's
going to come out of the hopper i want
new hampshire in charge of
denials and approvals there's no one
says the rules are going to be the same
for the fbi
and the state of new hampshire when that
legislation comes out of the offer
if it says the fbi may
delay 10 days all instant checks then
the state of new hampshire would not
have to delay
10 days and we would be in charge and
can still continue doing our instant
checks instantly
so um in the general gun control climate
that's in washington i think new
representative hopper you're recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
councillor wheeler for taking my
question
so is it your assertion
that the
state should bypass the federal knicks
check
if laws change in bc
to alter the next check as it is now are
you saying that we can just issue a lot
of
uh
thank you representative harper to
restate my answer it is it depends
on the exact language that congress will
come out of the harper with with hr six
should it even get out of the hopper nix
is just a database and how you do use
that database could be given discretion
uh to the states if they say
may delay then we don't have to it all
depends and i don't trust uh the way it
would come out of the hopper down there
and i think we need to stay in charge we
need that flexibility we need to be able
to fix it
when people are unjustly denied or false
information gets entered into that
database
representatives
for a question
thank you
mr chairman
account for the wheeler do you think
that the state should
give the department
more people to help the implement this
gun
line yes i support i support the
positions uh in the budget
um to give them the personnel they need
to make the checks 100 of the time truly
instant
and i think they've done a good job you
know using people who are uh
need light duty work on workman's comp
it was a good place to put them uh it's
a good place to use some troopers who
are actually troopers but they hadn't
gone through the academy yet i think
they're doing all they can to make it
work now but we do need those permanent
positions
representative also you are recognized
thank you very much
um thank you executive counselor for
being here today
um just to i think i need i think i
wanted to
ask you since the gun line has been i
have two questions first the since the
gun line has been in his existence since
and has
um served new hampshire through
five different presidential
administrations
two
republican administrations and
now going into a third democratic
administration
i heard your concern
that
somehow the gun line would be
irreparably altered from its
um
from the way that it's been moving since
1993 what is it could you elaborate on
first i would state that i think the gun
line has had problems in the past
because they did not have a fixed policy
at the state level
they have adopted the the knicks rules
of clearing the deck after 88 days
the knicks rules of 99
excuse me 90 of all checks will be
instant um
and i'm saying that the climate in
washington has never been as anti-gun um
as it is right now so things are
different today i'll also
hopefully you can see this 500 pages
of the next book the guidelines that it
takes to run nicks 500 pages
i don't think that the money is
sufficient for the counties to because
you talked about county money
representative i don't think that money
is sufficient to train those people and
you're going to train 10 different
counties to do the job that should be
centralized on one person um
at the state level it just isn't going
to work at the county level
representative you're recognized for a
follow-up question
thank you very much
um i would have i would agree um
executive councilor wheeler that uh
downshifting state responsibilities to
count to the county is is definitely
something we want to avoid because it
will raise our property taxes um my
question is that on page two of the bill
and i don't remember if you had said you
had it in front of you do you or shall i
read my
please read it
okay
thank you for clarifying so on page two
for those who are following along
page two lines eight nine and ten
it is um part one section c
nothing in this chapter shall be
construed to limit prevent or impose
background check requirements on the
private transfer of firearms as
otherwise not prohibited by rsa 1 159 or
federal law
so
um
regardless of anything else that's said
in the four pages in fiscal note of this
bill
um
there really is no infringement would
you say on
people being able to
purchase a firearm maybe not the one
they want at the moment but the second
amendment doesn't necessarily allow
supply you with what it is you want just
what you nest what you think you need so
would you agree with that question so
yes
your statement please ask questions of
the witnesses the last time i'm going to
make this warning for members of the
you room a question the witness the
witness
may answer but members are not
recognized to make a statement like that
sorry mr chair could you clarify where
um may i answer that well why is your
question not appropriate the ruling is
that it really wasn't a question then
you corrected yourself by saying do you
agree with me so they're asking me if
you agree with your question
i didn't correct myself that was my
question representative that's the
ruling of the chair
i will allow the witness to respond to
most part of that statement but the last
warning i'm gonna get because we're
gonna have a very long day
if people if the members of this
community wish to make
statements
you have my word you will be recognized
during an executive session
to make speak on the bill or
if you really want
you're free to testify
there's no rule saying you can't
the only difference is if you testify
you will not be committed to ask
questions
thank you mr chairman i would not
interpret that that language that way at
all i believe that language refers to
the private sale of firearms and it is
saying that none of this whole
background check stuff prohibits or can
prohibit the private sale of firearms
from person to person without a federal
firearms license dealer
and they still would not need background
checks
i want to thank thank the executive
council for his testimony
represents just a reminder your
testimony will be made in three minutes
hopefully i'll be done in uh less than
that i can um
so i've
learned a lot about a very complicated
issue i can only speak to the part about
um
about downshifting this to the sheriff's
office just i've been on the county
executive committee stratfor county
which is medium-sized counties our uh
our county sheriff's department like the
state police is already very very busy
um so
even if it only takes supposedly three
minutes to run a check on the computer
we have the dispatcher dude 11. that's
still a significant
burden on the one-time 10 000 payment
um it's uh probably inadequate even for
cowash county which is about the size of
a
dairy of the town of derry but certainly
it's grossly inadequate for stratfor
county and so it has to be paid for
somewhere probably the
fairest thing would be a
fee but that would be a new fee which is
uh very politically unpalatable
especially a new fee related to guns so
this is an unfunded mandate to the
counties and um
so even though those has to do with guns
which are maybe a higher priority for
some of us and other things that's still
a uh unfunded mandate i don't see why
if the state police
were struggling why uh
why county sheriff's department would
necessarily not just face the whole
issues if we dumped that in our lab so i
think that's uh
that's at least one sign for me that
this whole bill appears to me uh to be
um as we like to say
not ready for prime time so i think
probably uh
probably you're not
probably it's
it's probably my my general impression
is it's so deeply flawed there's nothing
you can do with it and you know the
limited time we have left work on it so
i would probably
recommend
it even though obviously the system you
have is not working uh working perfectly
so that's basically
that's basically just my comment on it
there's a lot of uh
i've learned a lot of technical details
a very very complicated issue and um so
i
only wouldn't presume to address any of
the other details but just downshifting
through the county that's especially
with no training and no expenditure
that's just uh going to be repeated
they're just going to have the same
struggles that the
state police did oh yes i'm on the
judiciary committee so i can tell you
the courts are not necessarily
co-located with the
sheriff's department's courts our
judicial branch is separate from county
government and actually a lot of these
orders probably most of them actually
are being
issued by uh
either the circuit court or the family
division in the circuit court so in many
counties you could be mine um no we're
not even that court doesn't even meet at
the courthouse so that's um
so anyway
you know this uh they put a lot of work
in this build but i think it needs so
much more work to be uh to work to like
pass i think probably just gonna have to
uh
put it aside and i tell it or retain it
or whatever so uh thank you i'll be
happy to take any questions although
you've
asked and heard a lot of questions
already
[Music]
thank you
testimony yeah
you know him
the representative you are excused
oh thank you
this time the chair recognizes richard
head
[Music]
good morning chairman navis uh members
of the committee my name is richard head
i am the government affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
um just to point it out the written
testimony the the joint written
testimony of safety and the judicial
branch was sent out on my outlook 247
yesterday afternoon if you want to if
you can locate her if you want to locate
it
and was sent to the link for
email to all committee members
my
goal today is to provide information
about the court's role differences
between the gun line check and the fbi
check as it relates to the role the
courts fill
currently we have staff that enters
modifies and removes information
um that relates to domestic or orders of
protection that are issued by the court
and and this is really indirectly
uploaded into the federal ncic database
we issue or we use the uh the spots
terminal system the state police online
telecommunications system
and from that so we input directly into
that system which then automatically
inputs into the ncic system
um nics is not itself a storage of data
it's been i would describe it more like
google which then goes out and searches
databases and as you heard searches
three specific databases ncic triple i
and the nix index
and our data goes into where we can
through the spots terminal into ncic
the really four areas in which orders of
protection are issued
domestic violence
petitions stalking petitions under the
child protection act
and bail protective orders um so those
are sort of the general areas in which
protective orders are issued
and that as a result of sort of that
statutory setup in the way in which
matters are filed with the court that
results in three places where data may
be found regarding protective orders in
those protective orders maybe
disqualifiers
one is the data that we input directly
through spots into ncic
the second is and you heard the
commissioner reference this where a
protective order is issued but the party
filing it does not know the date of
birth of the of the defendant
and those are not your criminal cases
those are civil protective orders where
the party who's filing simply doesn't
have a relationship with the defendant
that suggests that they know the date of
birth so we have and it's a
changeable list
of about 50 to 70 names at any
particular time
where a protective order is issued but
the the court has no information
available to it about the day of earth
and therefore we cannot upload it into
uh
ncic because that date of birth is an
essential component of what we put into
the system through spots so we have a
separate list we've
faxed that to state police
on a daily basis so that that is one of
the databases they check in addition to
nics
and then when the sheriff makes service
uh or or whatever the other system is
where we get a date of birth
we modify our list we input it into ncic
through the spot system and it comes off
the no known date of birth list
so at any particular time they're 50 to
70 some odd names on that list but it
changes regularly as we learn date of
birth they come off the list new filings
come on and they go on the list
and then the third category are the
emergency domestic violence or the after
hours criminal bail protective orders
cbpo
and they just
because there's a manual process for
inputting data into spots and therefore
ncic
you know that data has to get
there's a delay although state police
can have access to it it's not a long
delay but there is a delay
um so as a as a third check
uh gun line looks into that
if
if you don't have it in front of you
i'll describe it but on page four
of the written testimony we provided
uh of the joint testimony it has it
outlines three
uh
graphs about how these systems work and
what is reviewed and what would not be
reviewed if it changes to a fbi
mix check only
and currently the as i said you know the
big
issue is going to be the
list with no date of birth
where there's a protective order issued
the other is the emergency domestic
violence or the after hours criminal
bail protective orders
and then you also heard the commissioner
refer to the department of safety's
database where they have essentially all
the criminal cases
and in in what happens is they check
their database if it comes across a name
and that does not have on their database
and this is where i'll correct center
guido a little bit it's not
the judicial systems database it's the
department of safety's database of
criminal matters if they in their
database do not have a disposition of
that case
they contact the court clerk find out
what the disposition is if it was
something that at that point should be
uploaded into
one of the next databases they do so
um and if it shouldn't then it's not a
disqualifier
so the interaction with the court is
safety will reach out to the court
system find out the disposition and then
update their records and really what
we're talking about
is the clerk gets contacted for records
that are essentially
i think all the time
free brady bill uh matters that are in
the department of safety's database
the other thing that's missing and
described in our testimony is
under rsa 173b the domestic violence
statue
you a person
who is subject to a protective order
attempts to purchase a handgun
the courts are notified and the courts
notify the person who is protected by an
active domestic violence order
to inform them that there is an attempt
to purchase a weapon by the person who
the domestic violence order is issued
against
and that allows that person to take
whatever additional safety measures that
they believe is is necessary for their
own protection
if the fbi were to conduct that search
they would not be reaching out to the
courts to say that there had been a
contact
so that's a a
an element that would not be
followed
should the should the bill proceed
um
the other
the other aspect of it and is within the
bill itself
on page 3 line 22
it describes orders that are issued by
the court under 173b
which is the domestic violence
act
and 633 colon 3-a
which is stalking
in putting those directly into the
nix system
what's very unclear to us is what that
means
is because we don't directly input into
next we
indirectly input into ncic through the
spot system unclear that would still be
allowed but it does not include
and therefore we would not have under
this as written statutory authority to
enter into the system uh protective
orders under 169c which is the child
protection act or rsa 597 which is where
those bail protective orders come into
effect and they're simply not described
in uh in the bill
um
mr hey i do have to
i apologize i appreciate the the uh the
additional time
uh i'd be happy to answer uh any
questions that the committee may have i
but uh i i do appreciate your testimony
but i do have to ask someone who but
the chair voting require uh
would ask a question and i want to thank
you for taking my question can you
describe the process
of when if someone
does have a disqualifying uh condition
that can prevent them from purchasing a
firearm
it's in the mix
what is the
process of removing that
disqualification
like for example for domestic violence
expire
yep so it's similar to
the process of putting in
uh and again we go into the spot system
we have the um ability with spots to
enter to modify or remove
so as the status changes of a protective
order that data can be
can be done by our staff relative to the
to the protective order itself
um
and then with regard to the date of
birth
list
as we get a date of birth that is then
updated and uploaded into into
ncic through spots and then would come
off the separate
thank you thank you take my question
representative hoffa you're recognized
for a question uh thank you mr chairman
and uh thank you for taking my question
a little bit of a hypothetical
uh
let's say this year the federal
government changes the criteria
for a nix check
and
decides that any nix check will only be
issued
five days after it's been requested
does the state have the authority to
bypass that mixed check and issue
uh release to allow a gun sale anyway
so i think the
if i unders thank you for the for the
question if i understand correctly if if
you're saying that the federal
government change would prohibit
essentially would would have a required
five-day delay
i think the answer would be if the gun
line and i'm making an
assumption here under what that law
would say but if the gun line
were able to access
nics and were they able to obtain
information from nyx in less than five
days
even though the fbi might be limited and
prohibited from issuing
in less than five days it would really
depend upon how the law was written in
congress
if
congress did not prohibit a state from
a state authorized program from issuing
in less than five days
then they could issue unless then
and the person was qualified they should
be able to issue in less than five days
if congress preempts the federal or the
state program
uh from doing that then i i would assume
it would be required to follow the same
five-day rule
but it would depend on how congress
wrote that law
thank you
representative recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
you said
about domestic violence that the state
police have access to that
now
in the bill
we have the sheriff's that's going to do
that part if this bill
passes do you believe the sheriff will
do just as good of a job
as the state police is currently doing
on
making sure that nix understands that
this person is prohibited
so thank you for the question i did not
realize i went 11 minutes when you're
talking it seems quicker um
the the the one thing to make sure is
clear is that the sheriff's role in the
bill is limited to where there's a
petition for a return a firearm
and that's where senator gaido mentioned
there were about 450 500
and sometimes or as many as 600
but they would be essentially the
court's interface with the with the fbi
system with the federal system
and for those only the the sheriffs
would be uh responsible for getting
uh the next uh response back to the
court
so that we could determine whether or
not the petition for return of a firearm
should be granted or not
if it's a request from a federal firearm
a federal licensee firearm licensee
that does not as i understand the bill
go through the sheriffs that is a direct
fbi uh request
so just to clarify the way that the two
lines in which requests are made
separately that would specifically to
your question has written no the the
no date of birth list and the department
of safety's
list of of matters
would not be searched by the sheriff or
the fbi if it's the federal firearm
licensee that's
that's doing the the search
nor would they have
under the bill the emergency domestic
violence or the after hours criminal
bail protective order
list
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my follow-up um
but if i understand correctly the bill
instructs the courts to clean up their
records
which you know i understand needs
cleaning
and they are going to report this
you know to next
so
i thank you for the question
i don't think the bill requires us to
clean up our records one just on that
point the the records we're talking
about so there there's
in and i had mentioned this and i think
senator guida had mentioned this there
are about 170 000
records that are in the department of
safety's database it's not a court
database
in which the the department of safety
when they run the search on their
database if it hits one of those 170 000
that's where they call the court and say
hey what was the disposition of this
matter so that we can update our meaning
the department of safety's database
um there is nothing in the bill that
instructs a cleanup of that
um and as as
i put in my fiscal note um to the senate
which may be the one that you just
received because i asked the clerk to to
why it wasn't attached to the bill
um if we had to
um receive that list of 170 000 today
and clean and essentially find out the
disposition
of what is in department of safety's
records
there would be a a significant fiscal
note associated with that um with that
search because we would have to do it
essentially
uh all at once instead of the current
system which is if there's a hit
the department of safety reaches out to
us we spend the time to to find out what
the disposition is and report that back
to
and i think you had a second question
which i apologize i'm not sure i
remember i did not no okay thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and uh nice to see
you mr head um in a different committee
um my question today
my question today refers back to your
testimony you testified that
there
is that correct that there are 50 to 70
names at any particular time
that don't have a date of birth attached
and do you know
if um
[Music]
of those at 50 to 70 names at any one
particular time how many of those are
domestic violence
stalking or child protective
issues
thank you for the question they are all
within those statutes i had mentioned
domestic violence stalking or child
protection
so that's where the protective orders
are issued through
and
and as i said that's a 50 to 70 is is
about the average that will be on that
list at any one time
and it's a continuously changing list as
we learn dates of birth or
new matters are filed
where we don't have dates of birth and
again in our written testimony we
provided some examples of of how that
could come to happen
you know for example a store clerk who
is asked out on a date who declines who
then
the customer becomes more aggressive and
starts threatening
and ultimately that clerk
gets a protective order because of the
nature of the threats that are being
issued against that clerk the clerk has
no reason to know the date of birth but
it would fall within the stalking
petition but they don't have that type
of
relationship uh to know what the date of
birth would be
so when the when that ultimately that
complaint gets served the sheriff can
identify that or can learn the date of
birth from the party or in a filing uh
that it happens at the beginning the
court can get the date of birth and then
that list would be updated
and we try to do it obviously as quickly
as we can
but it is dependent upon when that data
can come back from the sheriff or
if not from the sheriff when the when
follow up please
representative also you're recognized
for a follow-up question
thank you very much
so mr head going
referring back to the example that you
just gave
um
since a uh the clerk in this example
doesn't have the date of birth but files
for an emergency protective order
through 633 for stalking um would the
person that is the file the the order
you know who had been harassing her or
him
um
would that person now because there's no
date of birth
attached to that
be in that in a space where they would
would be able to purchase a firearm
through
thank you um thank you for the question
if the check were to go only through
nyx so the part of the gun line that
goes through nyx or fbi which only goes
through nics
they would not see that person because
it can't the data cannot be entered into
the database without the date of birth
so they would just be invisible to the
fbi
but because
gunline does receive that list
and gunline does review that list when a
request
comes in for a purchase
[Music]
they would they would then be able to
say there's a disqualifying event
as a result of of the protective order
and as you heard from
lieutenant mcquade it does require some
additional research on their part
because you know they're not all john
smith they may have unique names but
they need to then identify whether or
not there is sufficient information to
say whether or not there's a
disqualifying event
but they do have that list and gunline
does review it every time they have a
request and if there's a hit and it's a
disqualifier
then uh
then that would be disqualified which
would not which would just not be seen
representative you're recognized
thank you mr chair thank you mr
question
obviously i don't know much about the
gun line i should be asking for a friend
but
somebody said
i think that the gun line is only
authorized
to use
the next system
data entry
my question is
if somebody's going to buy
that
the gun deal gives information to the
fbi and the fbi
runs a next search
as opposed to in new hampshire if
somebody wants to buy a
firearm
that
the gun dealer gives that information
to the gun line and they run a next
search
is there any difference between
the next search the fbi did the
writer
and the next search
thank you for the question i it's a
great question because um i do i think
it is worth clarifying
this this point which is really what is
the statute say
uh as to safety's role and it's 159
dash d colon 1
which says the department of safety may
become the point of contact for the
federal government for the purposes of
the national instant criminal background
check system next
and that's that's the statutory that's
the requirement in order to
uh to become a point of contact uh for
fbi
it is not it does not say
and really the the question goes should
go to the attorney general's office but
my understanding is the attorney
general's office
and the attorney general worked with the
department of safety to come up with the
policy based upon the statutory
authority
but it is not it does not say
department of safety you can only do a
next background check it is a an
authorizing statute which says
which is required
department of safety you are authorized
to become the point of contact for the
federal government
for purposes of nics and then
we have in fact implemented that and in
through what we
call the gun line but the the permitting
group at the department of safety
they are the the point of contact as
authorized by the statute it does not in
the in the c in the content of that
statute limit them to nix it just simply
says that they can be
uh it may be the point of contact
um but i think in terms of the authority
of
safety you know it's a better question
for
new hampshire department of justice and
the attorney general but it's at least
my understanding
that the attorney general has been
working with with the department of
safety and putting that policy together
within the context of the statutory
authority
thank you representative newman you're
thank you mr chair and uh thank you the
witness for taking my question
um
in the bill on i don't have all the line
numbers but on page two section
two
it says that rsa
d159 d1 and
159 d2
are repealed and re-enacted to read as
follows
it's very difficult when they put new
when they completely repeal something to
compare the new to the old
could you just briefly describe
what differences you see in the changes
i'm sure
they they are
uh
i think
fair to say nothing alike
um so 159d
uh
currently gives the gun line through
essentially the department of safety uh
authority to be the point of contact
and then 150 the current version excuse
me of 159 d2
it instructs the department of safety
regarding confidentiality
and section 3 of 159 it's only three
sections talks about the penalties for
the attempts to purchase illegally
so i think it's it's fair to say and i i
agree with your point it
becomes incredibly hard to compare when
it's uh just a complete replacement you
know the bold or the strikeouts but in
this case um i think it's fair to say
that this is entirely new
and uh and then by virtue of what's at
the end of the of the bill
um
under par under section five of the bill
it says
the new hampshire state gun line
in the permits and licensing unit the
division of state police department of
safety is hereby abolished so it
essentially eliminates the the gun line
in part five of the bill and this
section is entirely new and and i do
point out
you know this
in that in that section that you're
reading part page two
it references uh restraining orders
under 173b and 633 colon 3a which are
domestic violence and stalking but again
in that section similar to what's in
part three of the bill where we're
authorized to input data into nics
it does not include 169c the child
protection act or 597 the uh
the the bail
protective act
or i'm sorry the
criminal bail protective orders
they're simply not referenced in either
of those two sections of the of the
statute but both are important sources
of information regarding protective
orders
uh for for those who who
uh have protective orders to for their
safety
representative newman you recognize for
a follow-up question
[Music]
thank you and based on thank you for
that description
um and but
based on that
do you think that the changes that have
been made
to to those laws
would be more effective in correcting
the problems that that you wrestle with
as far as
being able to identify
people and being able to identify
whether uh the current uh restraining
orders and all that kind of things that
you mentioned
um
does it make it better or worse to be
able to carry out the changes that you
think you have done
as written the bill would
and and really actually probably can't
be written any differently if if the fbi
is doing the search
because
the purpose of this bill is to provide a
nics system only background check
it and that's the end of the search
under if this bill were to pass
and what that would not then ever
see
because the fbi simply can't see it
because it doesn't and can't be uploaded
to nyx
is the
um the list of 50 to 70
orders
or parties and the defendants in those
cases where we don't have a date of
birth
and that just can't change
or to um if
you know those that are the emergency
domestic violence or the after hours
criminal bail protective orders
which do not get immediately uploaded um
into the system
and and there even if there was a way to
put a
in my understanding is there's not but
even if there's a way to put a person's
name into
the nix index without if date of birth
and everything i've seen from fbi
guidance says that you need a date of
birth
but if you were to be able to fbi still
wouldn't capture that because they're
looking for person
and date of birth
and that date of birth simply doesn't
exist so the the search that is
currently done by gunline
would just simply not be replicated
through
uh through this process and and that's a
you know i get that's a policy decision
of the legislature
and so what my purpose my testimony is
simply to identify those areas that
would change substantively which are you
know there are these these
important areas where there is
a domestic violence
order
that would simply not be captured in a
in a short window of time by the fbi and
within that window a purchase a handgun
purchase could be made that under the
under the gun line system would get
caught
in a disqualifier would be identified
and and on the flip side uh as
commissioner said
in the nix database so for example if
sometimes you know the data doesn't
always get uploaded so if we have a new
hampshire resident who lived in georgia
and
and that
shows an arrest in the next database for
a disqualifying event but the arrest is
is relatively old
the gun line can reach out to georgia
and find out if there was ever a
conviction or if it was found not guilty
and that's data simply did not get
uploaded into nics because nix is only
as good as the data that's uploaded to
it
and if in fact that per that case was
dismissed or there was a no not guilty
finding
then what could come out as a delay or a
disqualifier from the fbi
would get processed by the gun line as
qualified because the additional
research that the gun line does
thank you very much for that uh
clarification and i think it uh it
helped a lot in clarifying the
differences between the two systems
thank you great you're welcome
you know for the hands right
[Music]
yes mr chair thank you
uh mr head
uh could you tell me i'm uh
representative district 13 rockingham
county
uh did you tell me how many sheriff's
i cannot know
i know when i drive by my sheriff
representative
sorry
i will
mr chairman i'm sorry if i could just
add one thing
so it was a statement and i don't
believe any response is necessary i'm
sorry
is the trying to avoid members making
statements when they're recognized for
questions apologize
see no further hands raised for
questions
i want to thank the witness for first
testimony
thank you
[Music]
at this time the chair recognizes
sean list
and as a reminder
testimony will be limited to the
three-man side will do a better job of
thank you members of the the committee
for allowing me to speak today are you
able to hear me i can't see the mute on
my yeah
perfect so my name is sean list i'm a
lawyer practicing here in new hampshire
i focus on the area of firearms law
sitting next to me is jim macleod the
owner of shooter's outpost we're
actually at shooter's outpost
as i testify now i'm not going to go
into my credentials and waste time i
will say that i spend a significant
amount of time in addition to gun law
representing domestic violence victims
through the domestic violence emergency
project it is a um a primary interest of
mine so i want to i want to correct some
things as quickly as possible
first off i just want to point out that
i think it's beyond clear now that the
department of safety and the judiciary
are in fact in opposition to senate bill
despite stating that they're taking a
neutral position you
they won't make a single positive
statement about the bill
all this being said
allow me to explain that
the next system first off is not just a
series of databases there's a call
center in west virginia that is staffed
with a massive staff that actually does
do research i'm not sure where this
false presumption that they don't do
research comes from
um
just to give an example it's very common
for people to be denied based on having
a domestic violence qualifier by the
feds
even though it's just charged as a
simple assault prior to joshua's law
passing in new hampshire and modifying
173 b
people were denied for that disqualifier
all the time
so this idea that they do not do
research is completely false the reason
that there is a delay
um sorry the reason that there's a
possible response of delay instead of
approve or deny is so that they can do
that very research
the the real issue um that
no one has addressed thus far regarding
the protection of victims is the fact
that right now
the state police yes for handguns
they're maintaining some sort of sloppy
paper copy or excel spreadsheet copy
record of restraining orders but they're
not sharing that information into the
knicks index
the vast majority of states and i
included the map in my written testimony
the vast majority of states do not use a
point of contact system
what they do is they're allowed by
federal law to upload state prohibitors
into the next indices
so the nix indices is basically the
catch-all for any prohibitor information
that a state
wants to enter
separate and apart from ncic or the
i database all you need to enter
a state prohibitor into that database is
the name and the date of birth or the
name and the social security number
now that list of 50 to 70 individuals
without a date of birth that is entirely
useless and this idea that oh the date
of birth may not be known because it
could be a stalking issue well those
restraining orders don't go into effect
until they're served on the person and
if the police are serving the person
they know that person's date of birth so
it's another just example of sloppy
record keeping
ours that our state statute rsa 159 d1
it simply allows nick's or sorry simply
allows the gun line to be
the point of contact for next that's the
intermediary nick still runs the
background checks there's absolutely
zero state authority and the gun line
does not operate under any agency rules
allowing them to do off-the-cuff
determinations regarding whether someone
is a prohibited person or not
in current the current system given the
fact that they're not sharing
restraining order information into necks
they may they may uh block someone from
buying a hand
uh
excuse me this uh training list i'd like
to actually suspend one moment you
mentioned that you were then you were
present with a jim
uh mccloud who's also signed to testify
uh because the timing did expire but if
you are together
uh if mr mclaughlin is gonna
uh mcgraw is to yield his time to you i
so mr mcleod will yield uh yields his
time um so that i can continue
testifying particularly in light of
attorney head testifying for more than
10 minutes and i'm trying to respond to
it um
so
i'm not sure where it cut out
but the point i was making is
our state statute specifically permits
the state tax as a point of contact it
does not permit it to do all these
additional checks they don't have any
authority to do that but the state could
be just putting that information into
nics
so
people who have active restraining
orders against them
they also would be prohibited from
buying shotguns put a different way
currently
they may block someone who's got an
active restraining order against them
from buying a handgun that same person
could go buy a shotgun or an ar-15
because of the fact that the department
of safety does not upload that
information into next
now
the gun line uses the excuse that the
delays are because of an influx and an
increase in calls
there was a 71 increase on the federal
level that nick's experienced it went
from
um
sorry i'm getting an echo there it went
from
just over 28 million checks in 2019 to
39 million 695 000 in 2020 and guess
what nick's kept up with it
the issue that we're seeing with the gun
line is the fact that
frankly we are allowing people second
amendment rights to be held at bay
at you know at the leisure bureaucratic
whim
for example
i represent individuals who
appeal denials of firearm transfers on
both the state and the federal level the
gun line is supposed to follow federal
law which requires specifically that
within five days of a written appeal
they provide a reason that someone's
been denied they simply don't do that so
the fact that they don't even they
don't even follow federal law makes it
very hard to accept the idea that
they're going to follow some agency
principles or agency policy in place
what's further concerning is the fact
that
these federal background checks they're
supposed to be done in accordance with
very specific regulations you know 28
cfr
25.5 and six
and very specific statutes what we're
basically being told is that the gun
line is taking it upon itself to do all
these extra checks that neither the
legislature or the department of safety
through rule making has set the
framework for
and
they're allowed to affect people's
constitutional rights kind of behind the
curtain
in the last year i saw people who had
guns taken away from them in court
that
even if
there was a restraining order that was
temporary three days it expired they
couldn't get it back for 10 11 months
there was a crisis going on at the court
level they were totally log jammed and
by the way right now there is no way for
a person who's wrongfully denied the
return of firearms to appeal it senate
bill 141 fixes that
it requires a very specific time frame
for the checks to be run
and also for it gives appeal rights for
individuals who are wrongfully denied
also let me make the point about
downshifting to the sheriff's office
the vast majority of background checks
that occur in the state
of the gun line are handgun purchases
the uh return of firearms in court
that's a secondary function
that's actually something that was
created by protocol 11 by the court
system not even by statute
and that's only about 400 to 450 checks
a year over all 10 counties according to
the
chief circuit court judge
these background checks for purposes of
the return of firearms are simple
so simple that the next system is
currently being used by police
departments all over the state to issue
licenses to carry and they don't even
get additional funding to do that
so this idea that it's going to be some
um you know
some arduous undertaking or it's going
to require significant funding is false
i just want to make the point that
as it currently stands what we're doing
is we are spending hundreds of thousands
of dollars a year
on a system that just adds an extra
layer of government bureaucracy when the
federal system
works all over the country
states that have piles of state
prohibitors like new york in
massachusetts they use only the feds
what we have here is a situation where
the department of safety does not want
to update its own records so that the
appropriate information is going into
nyx which would not only allow people to
enjoy the second amendment rights but it
would protect victims of domestic
violence
so i'm happy to take
frankly go ahead
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh the chair recognizes representative
panther lockus to ask a question
thank you mr chairman
and thank you sean for taking my
question
i would like you to give me
um
some reasons why you believe
that this is better
at the county level than at the state
level
sure so
so basically as far as the uh return of
firearms in court that that limited
function that would be served by the
sheriff's office
the reason that i think this would be
better is number one
sheriff's offices they are the only
constitutionally created police agency
in the state
they have regular interaction with the
court system
and frankly they do a lot of functions
outside of what uh officers learn in the
police academy so like right now they
serve civil process
right and they carry on functions uh
in unison with the court system
regularly
so having them
in the court
directly accountable to the court system
to judges a judge could frankly ask you
know the sheriff's office
so when can we expect a response on that
firearm related background check and
they're right there so um i think it's
it's just makes sense to change it from
the department of safety given the
issues but the sheriff's office seemed
you're recognized for a question thank
you mr chairman and uh thank you uh
i was hoping to hear
from the owner of shooters and i do
apologize that you had to use his time
you know to finish your talk
but i was
wondering
you know what is the impact on gun
buyers and owners with these delays that
have happened in the past and that may
so that's a that's a great question it's
been a significant issue so i represent
gun dealers all over the state and um
you know shooters outpost and jim
mccloud they're the biggest gun dealer
in the state and what i can tell you is
is that the delays caused by the gun
line
they have you know led to situations
where
firearms are just sitting not on the
shelves available for purchase
um sitting waiting for the state to come
back to them and
the issue is is that there's only so
much inventory that smaller shops can
can carry at any given time and having
it tied up they haven't received payment
for it there was a real economic
disadvantage that they suffered and the
delays you know someone asked earlier
why is it that the delays are occurring
um you know
being someone that's
in litigation depose the gun line
folks and
notably we don't actually ever hear from
the gun line people that run the checks
i can tell you there's a fundamental
misunderstanding of the prohibited
categories
and frankly um understaffing over there
and
just one other point to answer your
question
um
the delays are also frequently caused by
this
50 to 70 person list where there's no
date of birth because that's not enough
to block someone
who's prohibited but it certainly is
enough to delay someone who shares the
follow-up representative
you're recognized for a follow-up
question thank you mr chairman and thank
representative hopper asked mr head a a
pretty pinpointed question and he kind
of
you know he did pretty good dancing
around the answer so i just want to ask
you the same question
if i get it right
yes just ask the question please all
right
new hampshire state police when they do
their knicks background checks on
handguns will have to follow that rule
that law
that is absolutely correct and i would
suggest um that you know
if if other attorneys who don't practice
in gun law want to understand this
interplay better that they take my
continuing legal education course that i
teach the lawyers i'm doing it in june
what i can say about
federal gun law is that it it is
uh preemptive and
holds supremacy over state law that's by
article 5 of the united states
constitution the supremacy clause
the um
the nix system and federal background
checks they are governed by the national
firearms act of 1934 the gun control act
of 1968. the farm owners protection act
of 86 the brady act of 93 and the uh
lautenberg amendment
in 97 that added domestic violence
indicators
federal law
absolutely governs all background checks
there is no situation we don't have
state firearm background checks in new
hampshire we are carrying out the work
of the federal government and they're a
part of every step of it there's no
situation where we do an end run around
any federal regulations around any
federal laws pertaining to firearms
period
chair recognizes representative klein
knight for a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um moments ago um if i heard
you correctly did you say you
participate in selling uh firearms in
our state is that correct
do you have do you wish to be recognized
for a follow-up question representative
knight
representative all shirley you are
mr chair
and uh thank you for taking my question
mr list
um
i am i am unfamiliar with you so
um i would have i would have appreciated
hearing your qualifications and
background um on this but i've discerned
that you represent
um
gun dealers could you tell me are you a
registered lobbyist
i am not a registered lobbyist i'm doing
this 100
on a volunteer basis i represent gun
dealers in a
legal capacity not on a lobbying
capacity i'm not being paid to testify
my credentials are so again i represent
firearms dealers around the state i also
practice plaintiffs employment law i
also
represent victims of domestic violence
and
sexual harassment i'm a firearms and i'm
a certified firearms instructor a
competitive pistol and rifle shooter um
i belong to the national shooting sports
foundation
um and you know which is a trade group
for firearm affiliates um
i mean
basically i practice primarily in the
areas of guns and stopping people from
being discriminated against frankly
which makes me one of the most
controversial people in new hampshire i
think
representative knight
your hand is raised again do you wish to
ask another question
yes please mr chair and thank you
so uh my understanding now that i just
heard you speak is that you represent
people that do sell firearms your
clients directly will gain more money if
this bill were to pass correct
so i'm not sure if they'll gain more
money or not that's definitely a
possibility
i represent both dealers and i represent
individuals so i do
appeals involving denials of firearm
transfers for individuals on both the
state and federal level as well
ultimately
you know the
the gun line it going away because it
causes so many problems and i have to
threaten to sue them to get them to
answer so frequently
supporting this bill and and actually
i'm the drafter of this bill with
senator gaida um
you know this bill will actually hurt my
bottom line
because you know then there won't be as
many cases dealing with the gun line
that's funny
[Music]
we should be recognized for a question
yes thank you mr chairman thank you
for this question uh part six of the
bill uh references uh
uh immunity to the sheriff's point
representative wallace you kind of faded
out there at the end but i think i
caught the whole question
so the inclusion of that immunity
provision regarding the sheriff's
offices carrying out their duties under
the chapter was was
added after
um you know they had raised concerns
about possible legal liability etc uh
the you know the immunity as far as the
sheriff's offices go
it really won't have an impact on
individual
rights because of the fact that there is
such a well-defined appeal process so
the
checks for the return of firearms have
to happen within they have to be
initiated within 10 days finished within
15 days and an individual gets an
immediate appeal
at no cost if they're aggrieved by a
decision by the sheriff's office
so it's really a balancing
i want to thank the witness for his
testimony
at this time the chair recognizes gary
fisher
just to remind you testimony will be
within two minutes excuse me three
minutes
chairman abbas can you hear me sir
good afternoon chairman abbott members
of the committee my name is gary fisher
and i'm the chief deputy of the
hillsborough county sheriff's office
i've been a law enforcement for over 35
years i am also a federal fire alarms
firearms license dealer
i appeared before you on behalf of the
new hampshire sheriff's association with
a neutral position on this bill
we met with senator guida and worked
with him to craft some amendments to the
bill when it was introduced into the
senate however there is an outstanding
concern
we respectfully ask that you make the
following change to rsa 159 d
colon 1
2 b on page 2 of the bill
you'll see in that section that it
refers to when the the
motion is filed with the court
and the time clock begins to run i'll
quote from the from the bill the county
sheriff's office shall initiate the nix
background check within 10 business days
with the date of filing of the motion or
other pleading requests in the return of
firearms
sheriff's association is asking that
rewarding the date of filing be replaced
with receiving
in that particular section also under
159 d 1 2 b
within 15 days of the data filing the
motion
we'd request again that the data filing
of the motion be re
the only other concern that the
sheriff's association and it's been
addressed
quite a bit already is the cost that's
associated with it sheriff's association
is not sure what the cost
would be
involving these checks um i'm aware of
one county which would be co-ops county
that does not have the hardware to to
accomplish this um they depend on other
local law enforcement agencies to run
their checks for them
so
and i know that this has been discussed
and it's uh senator guida brought it up
in his opening
regarding being able to use a six-month
all 10 sheriff's office will be required
to train personnel regarding submitting
receiving and receiving mixed
information as well as the state and
federal guidelines as they relate to the
possession of firearms by prohibited
persons
additionally all 10 sheriffs are not in
positions to absorb the commitment that
will be required with the personnel they
currently have on staff
these are the issues that the uh the
sheriff's association are bringing
forward
um again we have uh we've we've
attempted to to address this with
senator geider in the onset and they
still remain unresolved
i'd be thank you i'd like to thank you
for your time and entertain any
questions if the committee has any
karen recognizes representative
pantalafest to ask a question
thank you mr chairman um i would like to
ask the question if the
sheriff has an estimated number of
thank you for the question um
we're unaware we're told that there's
between four to 500 of these checks that
occur on an annual basis um being from
hillsborough county being the largest
county uh i have to make an assumption
that this county would probably receive
the most
inquiries for the return of firearms um
the information that's been provided you
from other testifying
individuals is that it takes a short
period of time to run it that is correct
um we run it in through the database
which we we do on a regular basis for
other things um
it would probably be done by our
communications personnel with that being
said it would be an additional
burden that would be placed on top of
what they're already doing
so to say that we would need to
hire an additional dispatch or an
additional clerk that is unknown at this
point
we're not in a position to be able to to
to say whether or not that would occur
signal for the hands raised i want to
thank the sheriff for his testimony
at this time the chair recognizes kenny
dean
it's a reminder testimony will be
limited to three minutes
yes thank you um
my name is penny dean i live in concord
new hampshire
i'm an attorney i've been licensed over
20 years i'm licensed in maine new
hampshire massachusetts d.c circuit
admitted to the federal courts and the
first circuit court of appeals in those
areas as well as the united states
supreme court
and i won't take all the committee's
time with my firearm certifications but
i am a hunter education instructor a
pistol instructor and i have several
other credentials
but what's most important to me here as
a gun owner is this bill is poorly
drafted
in exhibits in every shape and form and
i certainly can't outline them all a
fundamental misunderstanding of how the
courts work and how firearms work
as far as how firearm checks works and
first of all my torts professor would
say back up the money truck and here's
what i can tell you as an attorney if
this bill passes i'm going to make
multiples of the money i make now
and here is why
if a person is denied a handgun
they get a denial number i send a
release to the gun line usually within
hours but certainly within 24 hours and
at most maybe a couple days usually
within a day a few hours the new
hampshire state police gun line tells me
why the person was denied they told me
the court the denial was in they tell me
the date of the denial
they tell me the docket number of the
denial and they tell me the specific
statute the person is alleged to have
violated
that means all i have to do is go to the
court and see if that is a disqualifier
see if it is my client
and it becomes a very simple exercise in
either saying yes this is my client we
have to get it annulled no it isn't my
client or no it's not disqualifying it's
very simple when i give the new
hampshire state police gun line that
information
usually within hours but i don't recall
it ever being more than a day although
it might have been they have an answer
back for me
and they
and it's i bring them certified records
and the answer is of course your client
is now allowed to purchase a firearm
because i don't bring them junk
information
now
if you go to fbi nics
and ask them you can literally be
waiting years and i call the circular
file you send them or the client asks
them why
and they will send you back a response
well you or someone like you may have
been
charged and convicted of something that
bars you from firearms and lists the
appropriate statutes that doesn't tell a
person how to fix it it doesn't tell
them what court it doesn't tell them
anything there's no way a person will
ever be able to buy a gun through the
next system with those type of answers
and i sent out to the committee and i'm
happy to send the committee these
samples of these letters
it's like a circular thing it is a
horrible horrible thing for a gun owner
fbi nix denies people their second
amendment rights every day of the week
and it's just an exercise in futility
and those who hire me to do that spend
tons of money people who go through the
gun line spend a small fraction and get
their issues addressed literally in
hours if not days
so anyone that tells you
that that's not the case i've been doing
this for over 20 years and it certainly
is the case the gun line
is really a protector of new hampshire
citizens second amendment rights
but more importantly if this bill was to
pass it's missing so many provisions
again i wouldn't have time to tell you
about
one of the provisions says
talks about an appeal well how many days
do you have to appeal to the supreme
court show me where that is in the bill
it's not there
there's all these mechanical provisions
that are necessary when enacting a bill
they're simply missing from this bill
and i think that's a huge problem the
other problem they've talked about is
for example in this bill
a person's firearms are taken but they
can still have ammunition and ammunition
components that's pretty interesting
that's not how it works under federal
law but this bill simply doesn't address
a lot of those issues
but the other issue is they talk about
this 24 hours person's going to get
updates of any modification or
dismissals modification or dismissal
prohibiting firearms ownership and this
is all found on page 3 of 5.
but what if someone actually looks at
the bill
you look at it and say wait a minute
the courts are not mandated it says the
court will update nics
why doesn't
i'm sorry
the the court it doesn't say the court
shall update nick's
it also gives them 24 out
thank you mr chair and thank you um
for your
testimony today
mrs dean i would like you to go through
for safety reasons for my new hampshire
residents if we were to amend this bill
and fix it what are some of the other
i have a whole bunch and i'd
respectfully say that this should be
itled i'm i'm absolutely opposed to the
bill because no matter how many fixes
you put
you can't or at least no one that i know
can control those in washington dc
the bottom line is if we have a problem
now with this we can pick up the phone
and go talk to the gun line we can walk
into the gun line you can't do that with
fbi nics you can't call a person who's a
decision maker you can't walk into their
office
so if you start in the beginning to fix
the bill
the first place that i would fix the
bill
is that
um
which is page 2 and i don't have the
line numbers because i looked at the
sections it would be section
roman or i'm sorry the 1596 d1
roman 1 number c
nothing in this chapter shall be
construed to limit prevent or impose
background check requirements on the
private
transfer of firearms not otherwise
prohibited that is an open door to allow
private background checks that is just
poorly worded and i am a person who is
opposed to private background checks
meaning if there's sale private sale of
firearms i'm opposed to that background
check this is an open door for that
so that's one thing i think would have
to be fixed
next um
what about civil proceedings they have a
process there for those whose firearm
was taken again this is in the same
section on page 2 159
d1
and roman 2.
they talk about order under
173b
633b
criminal proceedings what about any
other civil proceedings if you're
involved in any of those other civil
proceedings and your firearm is taken
away i guess you don't get it back
because there's no process here it's not
listed in here and any judge is going to
say to you the legislature means what it
says and says what it means if they
didn't put it in there it's not covered
and i can't do anything about it
next
if you look at that same page which is
page 2
roman 2
c
if the county sheriff's office
determines that an individual is
prohibited from owning or possessing it
says the specific facts relied upon
the specific facts are useless
you need a docket number
you need a court
you need a citation
and you need the why
those are the things right now the gun
line hands you on a silver platter
virtually immediately
that giving that basic information
should absolutely be required and again
i can provide the committee form letters
for years and years and years that the
gun line gives those things
and so why wouldn't that be required
here those are very basic pieces of
information
if you
i
i certainly appreciate the
detail of your testimony
i understand several issues or concerns
you have with this bill
there are other questions and other
members of the public presence and we
are already behind schedule so
do you have written testimony that you
can provide to the committee do you have
it already
i don't have written testimony and i
apologize i thought i was answering the
representative's question so i didn't
mean to go on i was going through it
answering the question but i i
from my understanding of your testimony
is
the questions
i'm i'm sorry do you want me to continue
answering or waiting for a follow-up i
didn't catch what you were saying sir
if you may uh you may continue answering
the questions i just sent them a
reminder that we do have other members
[Music]
yes sir and i will
i'm not going to answer every part of
the defects because um the chairs ask me
to be brief so i just want to let you
know that i'm hitting the highlights but
not all of the defects
on page three of five the very first
couple of lines which is essentially
roman numeral two
d
one two and three
it says the expiration of a deadline for
filing a petition or notice appeal in
the trial court
and they don't give
specifics for example you file a rule 7
notice of appeal in the supreme court
but they're not giving you specific
procedures and deadlines
so they have some for times in the trial
court
but not in the supremes
they talk about the appeals of denials
in 159 d2 which is also on page three of
five
and you have a right to request a
further hearing on the matter within 30
days of the date of denial that's
suggesting there was a first hearing
when one says further hearing it
suggests there was a hearing prior to
that
and it doesn't seem to be the case
unless they're talking about the hearing
where you ask for the firearms to be
returned pending a sheriff's department
check
the next error that i find is like i
said that it's in page three of five the
ammunition or ammunition components used
to be prohibited as well as firearms and
now they seem to be allowed
which is contrary to federal law
but i guess we're gonna do things our
own way here the other thing we have
here is it's going to take at least 48
hours for this to happen in some
instances because the court has 24 hours
if they follow the situation where they
send it to the department of safety
within 24 hours the department of safety
then has 24 hours
of receipt of this
to upload it into nyx that's 48 hours
but the other question is in certain
instances does the legislature under
separation of powers
have the authority to mandate the courts
let me ask the witness to suspend
answering the question that that the
answer is
we do have to move along i do apologize
if we have additional time i'll allow
you to continue answering that question
there's other members that also have
questions
so i recognize representative burke for
a question thank you mr chairman try to
keep the question direct
brief answer yep
over the last 20 years we have seen ups
and downs
with
the time it takes for a handgun to be
how are we going to fix the future
ups and downs
if we continue with the current system
with the state police
thank you for your question
representative here is what i personally
believe i believe the state police had a
rogue employee that was doing as they
chose when they chose this guidance from
the attorney general's office that i
believe is dated
i want to say it's in january but i know
it's of this year is very specific as to
the checks how they're going to be
conducted and what's going to be checked
it has made a massive difference in
what's done so i believe
unless someone was going to suggest the
employees just ignore the attorney
general's guidance
that things are fixed
i've talked to dealer after dealer who
tell me five to seven minutes is how
long they're waiting for checks because
i like everyone else calls the dealers
so i believe
that it is fixed they had a problem
they've identified it they've got phone
like rollover phone lines
so i know we can't guarantee anything
but i know people who wait longer on
nics
and i hope that's responsive i'm sorry i
don't think anybody can guarantee
anything with all due respect
representative
for a follow-up question thank you and
uh
you spoke on how it's easier to
fix a
denial of false denial in new hampshire
can you explain because i'm hearing from
the national groups that it's really
easier to go to the feds and to
fix this problem if you are um
and can you you know explain how the
feds are different from the new
hampshire
absolutely and what i'm also going to do
after i finish testifying representative
is send the committee
a bunch of redacted letters from both
nyx and the state and the proof is in
the pudding so let me walk through what
happens when you do when you're denied
by nics when you're denied by next if
the person chooses to go online they can
input their information into next and
nix usually comes back and says we think
your person is prohibited under federal
law you have a name and or date of birth
that's similar but we have to be sure
it's you so oh by the way give us your
fingerprints and so i'm thinking okay
they were sure enough that it was him or
her to deny them you don't need
fingerprints for a passport don't need
fingerprints for a driver's license but
they're going to demand your
fingerprints and they send you this
circular
letters they'll send you the same letter
ten times in a row
but that will not tell you the court you
were
can allegedly convicted in
the place you're allegedly convicted and
why specifically why you're denied
saying that you're denied under federal
law because you may have been convicted
of a crime for which you could have
received more than one year imprisonment
is not helpful it doesn't allow you to
solve the problem i have one letter
that's dated this year that i can send
to the committee and here's what the
letter from nick says even if you give
us
a criminal record check from the state
this is from certified that says you
have no record it's not good enough for
us in this case they claim person x was
arrested on this x date for crimex well
person x has never been arrested ever
for that crime
never been convicted and they don't
claim he was convicted they say he was
arrested it's impossible to prove a
negative i have another letter that said
we think you were committed to a mental
institution
if they think that they should be able
to tell you the date the city and the
mental institution but if you ask me
today to prove that i wasn't arrested in
kansas city i can't prove a negative not
by their standard they will not accept
even an uh state police clear record
there's no reasoning with him it comes
back to when my mother said you can't
have a cookie and i said why because i'm
the mother and i said so that's how fbi
nicks operates they simply won't give
you an answer and without an answer
you're never going to be able to buy a
gun
because they won't tell you why
they didn't say in concord district
court in june 1944 docket number abc123
you're convicted of violating rsi blah
blah blah that's a reason that the gun
line's going to give you and you can
debate it
nix will never do that
at this time
uh we're not gonna organize any more
questions with the witness and the
witness is excused
[Music]
mr chairman
i just uh you gave representative bert a
follow-up and i had a very good question
that i would would have really liked
answered on behalf of my constituents
and i just think it's with all due
respect i should be allowed the same
treatment as my colleagues across the
aisle
i i understand i understand what your
point of order you're making i don't
believe that that is an appropriate
point of order but
uh i understand that you're
[Music]
satisfied with the discretion of the
chair
uh i am trying to keep the hearing
moving along i believe that that's also
in the interest of the public
uh
the witness that previously testified is
very easily accessible if there's any
information you wish to get from her i'm
sure she's more than willing
to uh
to um speak with you and i can i believe
that this uh that will also be present
the following year
so accept my apologies we will not be
executing this bill that we should be
after the public hearings quote so we
really have the time to ask that
question
[Music]
hi good afternoon mr chair members of
the committee can you hear me okay
just a reminder your testimony will be
going to the two minutes
okay thank you so much i'll try to be as
brief as possible
my name is pamela keilig and i'm the
public policy specialist at the new
hampshire coalition against domestic and
sexual violence i'm here to speak in
opposition to sb 141 which would
eliminate the state's gun line and place
victims of domestic violence and
stalking at a heightened risk of lethal
assault in new hampshire thank you so
much for the opportune opportunity to
testify today
new hampshire's gun line as you've heard
serves as a state background
sorry i'm so sorry backup registry
allowing law enforcement in new
hampshire to conduct criminal background
checks when individuals attempt to
purchase firearms or petition for return
of firearms after they have been legally
relinquished due to domestic or sexual
violence incidents domestic violence
offenders are the most likely to murder
someone in the state so this system is
crucial to protect the lives of victims
this system has been in place for over
20 years and there are new hampshire
specific public safety concerns that
need to be addressed before we eliminate
the gun line and shift entirely to the
federal system i also want to reiterate
some of the concerns addressed by the
department of safety and the courts and
their testimony which we share
the transition from the department of
safety to the fbi will take a
considerable amount of careful planning
and coordination where all necessary
stakeholders are engaged in this process
this conversation has not yet taken
place and has not been confirmed whether
or not the fbi can fully transfer new
hampshire's gun line into the federal
system which i think you've heard so far
this morning
this means that we are gambling with the
lives of victims specifically i want to
highlight that as written this bill does
not ensure the same level of protections
currently afforded victims of domestic
violence and stalking under new
hampshire law as you heard from previous
witnesses this bill does not include all
types of protective orders currently
included in the gun line
and only authorizes
very specific protective orders under
173b and 6333 it excludes criminal bill
protective orders and
child protection protective orders under
the child protection act which is a very
serious thing to exclude additionally
the nyx system would not search the
emergency domestic violence orders and
criminal bill protective orders issued
after hours further limiting the state's
ability to adequately respond and ensure
that violent offenders are not able
to access
deadly weapons
secondly you heard about the issue with
um productive orders that do not have
the date of birth so i won't go into
detail on that but i'd be happy to
answer further questions if clarity is
needed but without the gun line there
will always be approximately 50 to 70
people with the ability to purchase a
firearm that are legally prohibited from
doing so
in conclusion while shifting background
check management to the federal
government could work someday the proper
work and planning has not been done and
if the current legislation were to pass
there could be lethal consequences due
to the serious concerns we have
regarding victim safety we are asking if
you would please consider voting itl on
this bill or consider making this a
study commission to grant us more time
to make sure this system is properly
vetted thank you so much for your time
and i'd be happy to answer any of your
questions
the channel recognizes representative
all schiller for a question and just
before you ask the questions on
representative wallace was the time
will someone else take that responsible
representative
thank you for taking my question
um uh miss miss keelig um could you go
back into your testimony and
i'm sorry could you just reiterate and
clarify the 50 to 70
um
restraining orders or protective orders
that would be missed by this what would
be the effect for those um
people who had taken out those
restraining orders or protective orders
that would be missed by this process
uh thank you so much for your question
this was uh what both commissioner quinn
and richard head from the courts were
highlighting regarding the
cases where a victim filed a protective
order but does not know the date of
birth of the defendant um so that is
that gap that they highlighted where
they're between being able to file and
uh get granted for the protective order
and then getting this protective order
served to the defendant the that without
that date of birth it would not be
entered into the nick system um so this
is
that 50 to 70 people are on average um
the than the amount of folks that would
be missed um in that gap um so who could
legally um get a firearm even though
i have a follow-up mr chair
senator
you're recognized for a follow-up
question
thank you miss keeling we heard
testimony today from from uh department
of safety commissioner robert quinn who
said he's um documented a 63
increase in gun sales
um as a
representative from the new hampshire
coalition against domestic and sexual
violence
can you speak to an increase in gun
related domestic and sexual violence
uh thank you so much for the question i
don't have any current data but i will
say from the 2018-2019
uh domestic violence fatality review
report that came out in october 2020 um
we know that they're about
40 40 to 50 percent of homicides in the
state of new hampshire are domestic
violence related so domestic violence is
a factor in those homicides
and we also know that firearms account
for about 50 percent of the causes of
domestic violence homicides um so it is
a significant concern
and that is why victim safety should be
really central and considered when we
are talking about changing our
seeing you for the hands raised i want
the channel recognizes jeff
kelman and just a reminder testimony
excellent so thank you so much for for
hearing my testimony today
i live in bedford new hampshire and
i've just wanted to share a personal
story personal anecdote in my own
experience i've actually gone to
buy firearms before both long as well as
hank handguns and the experience that i
had
with buying a particular handgun
um i have no reason to be
denied or delayed or anything of that
nature from any sort of you know
criminal or civil basis
uh you know clean record in that regard
and went to go buy a handgun wherein
i experienced a
five week
delay
from the gun line on a particular
handgun and this was actually i had
bought
more than one over the course of a
particular year
so this this was a follow-up that i had
bought and this particular gun was a
single shot uh 380 little obscure you
know uh firearm but the the fact is that
had i had mal intent and been trying to
do something harmful i would have been
better served going to a home depot and
getting a hammer frankly at that point
but the fact that i had a a five-week
delay i think
just for this and i've bought firearms
both before and since um and and seeing
what's what's wrong really with this
system
shows that you know frankly i would
think about abolishing it even if it
were free but the fact that it also
costs the state taxpayers money i think
it's just egregious and i'd like to go
thank you for your testimony the channel
recognized representative plan knight
for a question
thank you chair thank you sir for taking
my question um so if you had firearms
already in your home this wasn't a need
i mean first of all the fact that it was
a uh a single shot 380 as i mentioned
shows that again it's it it's
not really the lethal force of the tool
that was of concern i think the
the bigger concern is with the fact that
they're
you know what's the justification for
that five-week delay um you know given
as i mentioned there's there's no other
reason uh for delaying me and there
hadn't been prior or
thank you
see you know from the hands raised i
want to thank the business for this
afternoon
there's any members of the public who
wish to testify that have not testified
already please raise your hand
uh the chair is gonna
she's gonna recognize his representative
uh maria perez and just a reminder
testimony is going to be
thank you mr chair for uh give me the
opportunity to
speak against sb 141
my name is maria perez um is the
representative for district 23. i just
want to be clear
i'm not against anybody having guns
i just want to make sure that people
understand that i'm not against guns but
to be honest this bill
domestic violence
survivor it doesn't make make me feel
comfortable it doesn't make me
i feel the confidence that uh our
biggest things and getting protected by
this bill i feel like the language that
i keep hearing from this bill
when people testifying in support of
this bill is more they care about
the money and they care about the gun
gun owners there's nothing about this
bill that it says that like
this is what we care this is
like the concern about the domestic
violence victims and
for that i i will say please vote no to
thank you for your testimony
seeing no hands raised
i
oh there is one phone number mr chairman
just please state your full name uh for
the record
uh state whether you're justifying
support or opposition to the bill and if
you're specifying on your own behalf on
behalf of an organization
all
at right time the chair recognizes
alan rice
and
this will remind the testimony we'll
give him three minutes
yes good afternoon mr chair members of
the committee i am my name is alan rice
i am a resident of bedford new hampshire
and i am here as a
representative of gun owners of america
i uh submitted written testimony to the
committee you all should have a copy of
it and that will speak for itself
um what i would delight what i would
like to direct your attention to is the
back pages of my written testimony
um where i have submitted to this
committee
comments from
many
many grassroots gun owners and gun
dealers
who have experienced significant delays
um not 15 minutes
not even two hours
but
several days weeks and months
with problems
with the new hampshire gun line this is
not a new problem um this problem has
been going on for
over 20 years
it's never been instant in new hampshire
never ever ever a gun dealer would call
a clerk would take the information and
say we'll call you back and the callback
comes anywhere from 15 minutes to
days weeks and in some cases months
we have heard over the years the state
police have tried to fix it
the fix works for a short period of time
and things revert to the old ways
the purpose of me submitting these
comments
is for this committee to hear from
regular members of the public who have
been burdened and inconvenienced and
deprived of their second amendment
rights
because of these delays at the gun line
enough is enough is enough
this committee should vote senate bill
ought to pass
as submitted to you by the senate they
heard the testimony they heard the
concerns of the sheriffs they addressed
the concerns and amended the bill it's
chair recognizes representative burke
for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
could you explain
if a person is denied if
we only use nics
and not the new hampshire state police
how hard is it to
so
working for a national firearms
organization i have the ability to speak
with people across the country
and as you have heard the vast majority
of states
go through the fbi they do not use a
state point of contact
and when i talk to lawyers in these
states they tell me it is very easy
to appeal a next denial i'm not a lawyer
i've never represented people so i
haven't done it
but i go by what the attorneys tell me
and they tell me it's extremely easy in
many cases a person can do it on their
own they don't need an attorney
but yet in new hampshire the system is
so burdened and so complex
the person does need an attorney
whether it's
some of the attorneys who spoke here
earlier or somebody completely different
but they need an attorney it's a complex
labyrinth system and it's extremely
difficult
where the federal system is very
clinical it's on the numbers and a lot
of it's done by mail
and it's usually handled in a very very
just a small follow-up mr chairman
recognized for a small follow-up thank
you mr chairman and thank you for taking
with the current system with the new
hampshire state police doing backgrounds
through nics
what
are there
any benefits to the
new hampshire resident or business for
doing that
we we don't see any benefit on the
initial
system in new hampshire was designed as
an intermittent or an interval system
when the brady weight
in the mid 1990s required a gun buyer a
handgun only buyer
to wait
five days between purchase and delivery
of a handgun from a licensed dealer and
the only way to avoid the five-day
weight was if the state of residence
had some sort of a permit license or
check
which is why this was instituted
that five day wait um went away on
november 30th 1998 when a national
instant check system came online
and also extended the check to rifles
and shotguns as well as handguns
new hampshire's law had an automatic
sunset provision
but the state kept doing it for a year
under what we believe is an illegal
executive order i've written about this
in my testimony
and then a year later they passed what
the law that we have now that allows the
state police to be a point of contact
and quite frankly not only has the law
outlived its usefulness
the current law has far fewer checks and
balances and protections
than the law that it replaced in 1999
so no there is no benefit to new
hampshire doing it and there's a
detriment and the detriment is we are
spending state tax dollars using state
employees state resources state
computers
to perform a federally mandated task
that the federal government will perform
free of charge
representative
thank you
thank you very much mr chairman
thank you mr rice for taking my question
in um dialing back to your testimony
um i want to ask my question is
that excuse me
since new hampshire does not have
any kind of background check for private
sales
anything that's done
with federally licensed firearm dealers
rea
is it your testimony that um
the
that people are
impinged or
are unable to buy weapons because
in one arena there might be a delay but
in another arena arena
well there's a two-part answer to your
question representative sure so you are
correct new hampshire does not regulate
the matter in which people sell their
personal property
um and neither does the federal
government if they're not selling it as
a business if they're not engaged in the
business of selling guns for profit
so if you and i um were personally
acquainted to one another beyond this tv
screen we could sell one another
handguns and that would be legal
but many people that we hear from want a
specific type of gun in a specific
caliber in a specific color and the only
way to get exactly what they want is to
go to a federally licensed gun dealer
and say i want that
and it's the gun dealers who are
required to conduct these checks and
these checks as i testified are subject
to massive delays
and so the dealer's business is harmed
the gun buyer has to wait i mean we
don't believe
it's in any way a crime fighting
tool um because if it was the states
that had significant controls with
permits to just have a gun in your
bedroom
would have far lower crime rates than
new hampshire and the actually the
opposite is true the states with these
government-issued permission slips and
restrictions and permits
have higher crime rates and more
violence than new hampshire like chicago
and new york
so
we don't believe the system is a
consumer fraud we don't believe it works
anyway there's a ton of false positives
and in the specific new hampshire
state gun line the delays and
inefficiencies have gotten to the point
where it needs to be abolished disbanded
representative i'll show you recognized
for a follow-up question
thank you very much
mr rice in the previous testimony we
heard from the new hampshire coalition
against domestic and sexual violence
this particular piece of legislation
leaves a hole in it where survivors of
violence and victims of crime
can further be exploited is that a
concern at all to the new hampshire gun
owners association well first of all the
organization is gun owners of america
and i am the new hampshire state
director
to answer your question i would
encourage all of those survivors to buy
firearms seek out professional training
and take responsibility for their own
personal safety and security
we should not hamper the vast majority
of new hampshire residents who do not
commit crimes who do not commit violence
and make them wade and be delayed
because a small subset decides to become
criminals
representative
recognized for a question a quick
question thank you mr uh chairman uh
thank you mr rice for taking my question
earlier today we had a representative
from the leader firearms coalition
uh testified against speech sp 141
and now you on their website are are
according to the nhse website you are
the president of an hsc
and you're testifying for the bill so
i'm trying to understand the confusion
i have not been president nor affiliated
with nhfc since
2019.
i work for gun owners of america
and for a period of time i was doing
double duty because i have worked for
gun owners of america since the mid
1990s
just
so so they're uh thank you
so their website is incorrect
i can't control the website of an
organization that i'm no longer
affiliated with
very much recognize her question
thank you chairman
uh mr rice so if i heard you correctly
you just stated that
the turnaround time to obtain a gun
is more important
than protecting survivors is that
what i said was i would encourage
survivors to buy a firearm and learn how
to use it and take responsibility for
their own personal safety and quite
frankly my organization finds it very
objectionable that new hampshire has
more restrictions
on the purchase ownership and use of
firearms than those that are found in
federal law and the majority of other
states and i'm specifically referring
to the restrictions not on those
convicted of domestic violence not on
those convicted of stalking but those
who are merely accused and subject to
court orders those are not federal
prohibitors those are mere accusations
and you should not lose your
constitutional rights over an accusation
follow-up
representative you're recognized for a
thank you so your solutions to this is
to put the onus of owning a gun on
domestic
violence survivors
instead of
looking at this as i mean this is just
prohibiting i mean looking into this
further you want to put the onus on
domestic violence survivors
so you have
your guns in a timely manner
what i said
representative is that
if someone is a victim of violence
they should buy a gun learn how to use
it and take responsibility for their own
personal safety
americans as a group are self-reliant
and if you become reliant upon
government you generally lose
people who have been subjected to
violence which is wrong and we condemn
it
should also take responsibility for
their own personal safety and as a
firearms instructor i have trained
many victims of domestic violence and
when i have been told
of what their case is
i usually give them private lessons so
they don't have to sit in a large group
representative klein knight you were
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you sir
for taking my question
so am i to believe that if a victim
doesn't have enough time to buy a
firearm train themselves how to use it
and instead
winds up
murdered it is their fault and they are
being irresponsible
i think you're over sensationalizing
representative first of all if they
don't have enough time to buy it it's
because the state police gun line
doesn't work
second of all it doesn't take an
eternity to learn how to use a firearm
third of all
the vast majority of people who obey the
law and follow the law
should not
be delayed
and have their rights hampered
because new hampshire has a more
restrictive statute with respect to
domestic violence accusations not
convictions accusations
than the federal law and we know from
experience that defense and deport
divorce lawyers use these accusations as
a way to gain leverage in court
proceedings and oftentimes it comes out
that they were lies anyway
you were recognized for a follow-up
question
thank you so earlier in your testimony
you said we should be relying on the
federal government to do these
background checks but you just said that
we're too reliant on the government and
that you don't trust the government to
do these background checks can you
clarify your stance
you're twisting my words
what i said was the new hampshire gun
line has proven that it's an inefficient
system it doesn't work people have been
forced to wait in some cases months to
purchase a brand new handgun
the federal system which checks the
buyers of rifles and shotguns has proven
to be a very efficient system
people are approved in a
matter of minutes and they walk out with
their new purchase in general we are
opposed to background checks to begin
with
but if we're going to have a check and
we're going to be stuck with this
federal mandate
why should we have a second set of
bureaucrats at the state level and give
them the ability to foul up a gun sale
when one set of bureaucrats is bad
enough
but thank you mr rice seeing no further
hands raised i want to thank to win this
first testimony at this time the chair
recognizes
the testimony will be limited to three
minutes
thank you i will try to be incredibly
brief because i know the committee's had
a long day um chairman abbas vice
chairman welch and distinguished members
of the committee my name is lauren
lepage and i'm the new hampshire state
director for the national rifle
association i'm here to testify in
strong support of this critical piece of
legislation and we want to extend our
sincere thank you to senator gaida for
putting this bill in i've submitted
written testimony so for the sake of
brevity i will just summarize it briefly
for the committee the vast majority of
states are non-point of contact states
meaning that they use nics for all of
all of their firearm purchases i believe
the exact number is 36 states use the
next system
and although it's appreciated the gun
line has tried to increase efficiency in
new hampshire
it is absolutely no
no guarantee that the delays will not
occur again there is absolutely no
excuse for ju
for justifying jeopardizing someone's
right to self-defense because of a lack
of government resources when the next
system is readily available
this bill is simple it authorized the
fbi to conduct all checks similar to
most northeastern states including
massachusetts new york maine
vermont rhode island it streamlines the
background check system it reduces
delays and it will save taxpayer money
and this bill is the only way to
guarantee that delays will not return on
behalf of the thousands of members
across new hampshire we strongly urge
the committee to support this bill i do
just want to take a brief minute to
respond to a question asked earlier by
representative al shuler about how many
new gun owners purchased firearms in
2020 um according to the national
shooting sports
foundation approximately 5 million
americans bought their first firearm in
2020 that accounted for roughly 40 of
firearm purchases for people who did not
previously own one
um so with that um i think i've hit all
the high points in my testimony thank
you
mr chairman if you would like i could
thank you appreciate it chair members of
the committee
my name is jake mcguigan i'm managing
director for state affairs for the
national shooting sports foundation we
are the trade association for the
firearms industry we represent
manufacturers retailers ranges across
the country
two of our larger members are based in
new hampshire being ruger and sig sauer
just to correct uh miss
lepage's uh statistics it's actually
eight million new gun owners that's a
more recent number
of those eight million new gun owners 40
of them are female and we've seen a 63
increase in
african americans purchasing firearms
for protection uh in their homes
this has been quite a contentious
hearing
for the past four hours and i appreciate
everyone spending their time uh you know
sitting here
what i like to point out is that i think
that every single person on this
committee on both sides of the aisle
should want to make sure that prohibited
people are not gaining access to
firearms and what continued to come up
in this and from the trade association
the last thing our members want is for
for prohibited people to gain access to
firearms
what people need to realize though here
is we continue to talk about the
domestic violence issue
with the handgun and with the gun line
we know the gun line's broken without
this bill they would have come and tried
to fix this
the gun line
it's been broken people waiting months
for firearms
our retailers could not conduct business
and they could not really
you know sell the firearms that they
wanted to sell but what we need to
realize is
that if all these records are being held
in new hampshire and in the courthouses
and not shared with the federal system
individuals
and victims of domestic violence
will still be at risk because those
individuals can buy long guns meaning
a semi-automatic rifles in shotguns
how is that any different they're still
going to be at risk what we want to do
is if it's such a big issue in new
hampshire and they have all these
secretive files that they're not using
shouldn't those files be and shouldn't
be we we be using the nic system
again it's only going to take a tragedy
where individuals are going to have to
point fingers at each other and
legislators are going to point fingers
and say well how this individual get
this firearm very similar to the
manchester uh cops that were shot by an
individual who should not have had that
firearm so again as a trade association
we want it to be streamlined we want to
be efficient we support sb 141 and we
also support those rights of domestic
violence victims but i think
they are being exposed to
um
really an issue because of
the new hampshire not sharing those
records and the ability for individuals
to purchase long guns because they're
not using the gun line
thank you very much i'd be happy to take
any questions for that
and i'll try to keep it short so thank
you
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
in your experience
nationwide
with states that have you know that go
directly right to next and they don't go
to their state police like we do
and then states like new hampshire where
we
buy a handgun goes through
state police they go the knicks
have you
what are the
issues that you see that are different
from the state's point of contact
representative byrd i appreciate that
question
what we have seen in those states that
have their own in-state systems we have
situations with delays we have systems
we have issues with staffing we have
some states out west that actually
started to charge for background check
systems in order to cover their costs so
essentially what it ends up being is is
a what we would call a poll tax or a
second amendment tax on the purchase of
a firearm
but what we've seen recently with covet
over the past year
is that some states that did not
recognize the firearms industry as
having essential businesses
if they had an in-state background check
system they had the ability to shut down
those background check systems
and then those individuals would not be
able to and our retailers would not be
able to sell
those firearms more specifically that
would be new jersey
which did that and did shut down that
background check system thus limiting
the ability to conduct business and then
secondly
with business with budget constraints
we do see a lot of
retailers impacted
by furloughs or changing of hours
many states don't keep retail hours
they'll do their background check system
from 10 am to 4 pm and obviously many
people will go and purchase firearms
after the work you know after work hours
so
you know and we're seeing that here
specifically in new hampshire because
they are kind of controlling that gun
line and you know obviously they're
trying to say now that it's much much
more efficient and quicker again without
this bill that wouldn't have happened
but it's only going to take another
situation where they're going to pull
back uh and have have that but the
states that go to the fbi system i mean
we're dealing with two to three minute
um
you know background checks
obviously you have to fill out your 4473
and do all that but there have been in
the past 10 years
the only outage of the nyx system lasted
probably about an hour because of an
upgrade to some uh software so
that would be the big difference that
new hampshire would be impacted by
mr chairman
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my follow-up
have you seen any administrative abuse
on
check systems with the point of contact
states
we have
most recently
some of our big box and what i mean by
big boxes i mean a cabela's or a
sportsman's warehouse or bass pro shops
out west
specifically in the state of nevada
there are
two count them two
people answering phones in nevada
as you can imagine with covid they've
had
las vegas has been completely decimated
from a revenue standpoint which
obviously is impacting the state budget
so we have large big box retailers that
now have one dedicated person on staff
whose job is basically to call in or
continue to redial to call into the
state in order to get a live person and
then have a stack of forms
to conduct that background check um you
know they'll have you know be waiting on
40 or 50 of them so those are the types
of abuses we see because again
the state's paying for it it's a budget
impact and if they're have budget
constraints they start changing the
hours they start furloughing or they
just um you know aren't answering calls
we never see that on obviously in the
federal system i've been to the knicks
system in martinsburg west virginia an
amazing facility
great people there they do a great job
and they can turn around background
checks in less than two to three minutes
and
background checks that our retailers can
be confident in
again our retailers want to make sure
that when they sell that firearm it's
not going to a prohibited person right
they don't want a knock on their door
two days later after a horrific tragedy
saying
why this gun you know
you sold this firearm and they're
basically in the media limelight
spotlight because of that
so that's we our guys just want the
confidence that that when they transfer
a firearm it's going to be done right
efficiently and they can be confident in
it thank you
thank you for taking my question
you represent a gun manufacturer's uh
trade association and you say that uh
uh 8 million guns were sold across the
country last year i'm curious what the
economic impact of the delays
specifically of the new hampshire gun
line
what that has been on manufacturers like
the ones you represent
yes um thank you representative
the
uh statistics actually is eight million
new gun owners that's not total number
of guns sold in in 2021 um
we do it it is a bit of a hardship on on
our guys because if we look at it from
the federal standpoint right let's
assume a consumer comes in and fills out
the 4473 which is the form that everyone
has to fill out it's a federal form when
you purchase a firearm
and
you end up
um the delay ends up being two months
okay
well that 4473 is only good for 30 days
okay based on federal law so it puts our
retailers in a bit of a
situation because now you basically have
to go back to the the person that want
to purchase a firearm have them redo the
4473 and start the process all over
again so the concern becomes is you know
we in i probably should not i won't say
the state but a state that does do their
own background check systems
uh system and they were having probably
four to five week delays
told our retailers in this specific
state
oh don't worry about the 4473 expire and
you can still transfer that firearm
i mean
you know and that puts our retailers
license their federal license on the
line
so the economic impact i would say it
unfortunately just it slows down the
course of business you know the new
hampshire retailers are not
i mean
i'm i'm based in
both i've been based in connecticut and
in massachusetts in both states use the
federal system in both states are very
efficient and compared to new hampshire
i wouldn't say that they're very uh
compare comparatively pro-gun states
thank you representative
um
what i'm
what i'm wondering is it it sounds like
there have been some
some inconveniences to manufacturers
maybe a little bit of lost money
um the situation that the state police
are trying to avoid
um through the current system seems to
be one of
preventing
people from actually falling victim to
domestic violence
uh
so i'm curious what your industry's
stance is on protecting
um
uh uh
people from domestic violence is the
answer just as simple as getting uh as
many women in that situation as possible
uh to buy guns or do you think that uh
government actually has a larger role to
play in the process
thank you representative um as i
mentioned in my testimony
i think it's being disingenuous to say
that the
gun line is protecting domestic violence
um
survivors
reason why i say that is because if an
individual and
let's look at the national level right
what do we keep hearing about we keep
hearing about quote unquote assault
weapons bans
okay
so if we hear about assault weapons bans
well that usually will be impacting
modding sporting rifles
so what is the one firearm that a person
in new hampshire that allegedly is in
these in-state systems can go and
purchase and pass a background check
and i'll answer the question that would
be a modern sporting rifle or a shotgun
so the state of new hampshire is not
doing
anything to protect domestic violence
victims with the gun line
because that individual if they want to
commit a crime
and they are not those records of not
being shared with the federal system or
with nyx they will simply go in and
purchase a long gun and i'm not saying
specifically in new hampshire because
federal law says
as a resident you can go and purchase it
in vermont you can go and purchase it
you know in maine
so
again i sat here as long
along with everyone else here for over
four hours hearing about this domestic
violence in in in
how new hampshire is protecting those
victims they are not protecting those
victims i'm sorry they are not now do i
agree that maybe uh you know the
domestic violence victims should
make a decision and and want to get
training and get a firearm to protect
themselves that's entirely up to you
that's entirely their choice but to
continue to say that new hampshire is
protecting domestic violence victims is
[Music]
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
we have a single point of contact now
with the state
the
rep newman you muted yourself
what happened
okay let me let me try one more time
we have one point of contact in the
state right now and this bill would have
points of contacts in all the counties
in the states however many there are
what makes you confident that
going through the counties will be more
efficient and have less delays than
um excuse me
thank you representative for the
question
again if the counties or the state
are doing their jobs correctly we
wouldn't be having this situation
right if the state was
efficient
in running a gun line
correctly
but again it's you're doing a double
process it's already a taxpayer funded
nix is already a tax payer funded system
and i would hope
and but we do run into this issue
elsewhere and we've run into this issue
in numerous states where
the court systems or the states
themselves are not sharing the
appropriate records with the federal
system or with their own internal state
system
so the less bureaucracy we can get
probably would be better but i would
hope that these court systems and these
county courts would be sharing those
records that's no different
let's look at it this way it's no
different than a felon right i would
hope
i would hope beyond belief that they're
sharing that those are convicted of
felonies would be sharing those records
from the county courts or from the state
and if they aren't then we're in a very
i guess my confusion is we have we say
that the gun line's not working but the
for the long guns it works
why is this build better than
doing it exactly the same way we do long
guns or am i just confused about what's
going on
uh with all due respect representative
newman that's exactly what this bill
would do it would be make the gun lines
thank you
yes sir
representative
thank you very much and um thank you mr
miss mr mc mcgorin i'm sorry it's okay
mcwiggin is fine oh jake don't worry
thank you
i appreciate it thank you for the
correction
um
i just want to dial back to
um some of the testimony that you just
gave or perhaps the answer to a question
that you just gave about um domestic
violence because it really is
um it really is a big concern um for
this particular piece of legislation and
i'm wondering if you were familiar
um with the new hampshire statistics i
know you gave us some national
statistics but according to did you know
that um in new hampshire fatality review
nine out of ten domestic violence
homicides are
are caused by firearms um and those are
handguns and
so 50 of the firearm deaths
of the of that only one in ten are
caused by long guns so um we
we really do want to make sure that we
are not creating a massive loophole um
representative i i appreciate i
appreciate that question but as you know
if if somebody is
um bent on committing a crime and let's
assume that
you know the gun line was not doing its
job of vice versa they're going to find
other means to to commit it and you know
commit the crime unfortunately um you
know i do point to many of the
statistics um from the department of
justice on the federal level dealing
with criminals right i mean if you're
going to be a criminal you are more than
happy to see um you know further uh gun
control policies put into place because
it's going to limit those you know
you know law-abiding citizens to to
exercise their rights so
yes if
let's assume there is an individual
where the gun gun line does stop that
domestic violence from happening
then that person would
go the next door and buy a buy a rifle
or shotgun unfortunately
and
if
the stats that you are saying are
correct that 9 out of 10
in new hampshire then obviously the gun
because they should have already been
denied their purchase of their handgun
if they did have temporary restraining
orders so nine out of ten crimes would
not be committed with a handgun
so you know forever andreas i want to
thank the witness for his testimony you
are excused at this time the chair
recognizes paul mark marquis
mr reminder testimony will be limited to
right
there's any members of the public who
have uh
wish to testify not testified already at
this time please raise your hand there
is a phone number
you wish to testify just please identify
yourself whether you're testifying in
support or an opposition of the bill
and whether you're testifying on behalf
of yourself on behalf of an organization
and your testimony is something for
good afternoon this is jay simpson
calling
can you hear me
yes we can hear you
excellent
i am a federally licensed firearms
dealer have been so in new hampshire
since
mid-1993
i represent myself
rarely have i heard so much miss and
disinformation in one hearing as i've
heard today
i can't possibly in three minutes
address all of the errors
uh but the representative from the nssf
is categorically wrong when he said that
quote of 4473 is good for 30 days
if a person fills out that form
and is called away from the dealer
the dealer calls and gets an approval
that approval is good for 30 days
but if the dealer never calls in
the request for a background check the
contents of that form are valid until
the dealer calls it in
so
therefore if a person fills in the form
and leaves and goes off for months and
months and the dealer doesn't call it
until the person returns let's own the
form is perfectly fine
there's a specific box on the form to be
filled in
if once an approval is received there is
then a delay
in the turning over the firearm then the
person has 30 days after the dealer
calls it in to come back to the dealer
and complete the transaction
a
couple of other issues i'd like to
address i will send in testimony
at the end of 2018 according to
department of justice statistics
published in firearms commerce in the
united states there were about 423
million firearms in the u.s excluding
military items
the idea that has been suggested to you
that if someone is denied they do not
get a firearm is
simply wrong
there are so many firearms available
that a person who is determined to get
one and who is denied will get one they
just won't get one from a licensed
dealer
now turning to the core issue at hand
only those who believe that the
commissioner of public safety is a liar
and a cheat
would have the gall to state to you
that if it weren't for this bill
this would never the long delays caused
by a rogue employee would never have
been fixed
not so
i think commissioner quinn is a truthful
man
and therefore
the improvements to the process that
have been made will be lasting
the
concept that fbi nix is bulletproof is
wrong i will send to you a copy of an
email that i got as a dealer from fbi
nix on 19 march 2021
saying that because of the volume of
clearance requests you will encounter
delays when you call fbi nics
the
i'll call it the firearm a feeding
frenzy
goes on at a slightly more moderate pace
than it did in 2020
approved or at least processed
39.7 million requests a 40.3 percent
rise over
2019. for the first three months of 2021
they the number of requests
is 36
up on 2020
and these are data released by fbi nics
they release them every month
so in short fbi nix is not bulletproof
the other thing that you were not told
is that for those who have a security
clearance or have had a security
clearance they will often be delayed
by fbi nics
if there is not at the fbi nick center
a person with a security clearance
sufficient to allow them to look at
the records of someone who say was a
seal or a member of delta force the
first line agents at fbi nick center and
by the way these are contractors these
are not government employees cannot look
at certain records
so
after 20 years of war in southwest asia
there are more americans and by
definition more new hampshire residents
who have held security clearances
and who are more likely to get delayed
by fbi nics
the state of new hampshire does not
delay such persons
because the folks who do these
background checks are state of new
hampshire employees we presume them to
be honest and upright
and they mostly are
and therefore they can look at all the
relevant records
one point i'd also like to address
is that
for victims of domestic domestic
violence
there seems to be an assumption that
they are somehow entitled to protection
this is not u.s law here's the law in
the words of
a federal
circuit court
but there is no constitutional right to
be protected by the state against being
murdered by criminals or madmen
it is monstrous if the state fails to
protect its residents against such
predators but it does not violate the
due process clause of the 14th amendment
or we suppose any other provision of the
constitution
the case is bowers versus devito
the legal site is
f2d
federal second 686
page 619.
my point is
those who have been victims
of
domestic partners who are violent
should not look to the state
because they do
not yet
mr mr simkin i do have to we are
limiting testimony three minutes before
witness i will ask you to conclude your
[Music]
it's time to again recognize paul
marquis
it's a friendly reminder your
testimony is limited to three minutes
i just simply want to say that as long
as uh the dealers are given a choice
between the knicks and the
directly to the knicks and the
state gun line
there would be
no issue
um
as it is abolishing the gun line
is is
not sustainable
thank you for your testimony uh senior
are there any members of the public who
wish to testify that have not testified
already
is that three five nine numbers yeah i
see three five and then jeff gellman
[Music]
senior members of the public with their
hands raised at this time we will now
close the public hearing on senate bill
141.
this time we will now open the public
hearing on center field 154 national
library of the state enforcing
the presidential executive order that
the switzerland is the right of the
people of heat and bear arms
again uh with the exception of the
uh
person or the member who introduces the
bill uh we'll be listing testimony to
of course members are limited to two
questions per witness
is there is there a senator president or
a representative to introduce the bill
we're a member of the committee i'd just
be so kindly you can simply just
introduce the girl
nothing more
okay the chairs recognizing
representative chris true
to
just introduce um
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record i am
representative chris true
dr ham district 4 representative of the
great town of chester and sandown thank
you for this opportunity mr chair to
introduce senator 154
an act prohibiting the state from
enforcing a presidential executive order
that restricts or regulates the right of
the people
if there's any members of the public
wish to testify at this time please
raise your hand
and again uh testimony will be limited
to
this time the chat recognizes jeffrey
shane
mr marquis who waited so patiently to
testify after a very long hearing how
about we give mr mckeester courtesy of
letting him testify
on behalf of bill 154 right now what's
this is uh paul marquis representing
myself in uh new hampshire firearms
coalition
on in regards to
senate bill
154 um
i like to go to uh
say we we support the bill as it
we do not support the bill as
it is written
uh and would suggest that an amendment
be made that would uh
include protection from federal
laws that are passed uh
regarding firearms
uh
acquisition and uh
possession in the state of in in
on the federal level
that uh
resources would not be used to
enforce those laws
um
thank you again for your testimony
see no hands raised the witness is
excused
markinsky
good afternoon uh mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is joe
hannon and i'm the vice president for
gun owners of new hampshire and i stand
in support of this bill as amended of sb
um
you know we we know that executive
orders are
are written as directives in the present
united states that manage the operations
of the federal government
they don't have a mandate on state
governments and what their agents are
supposed to do he's not the chief
executive of states
governments and
officers
congress and legislators can pass
legislation that can make it difficult
or even impossible to carry out that
order the federal level they can remove
funding in the congress at the state
level they can forbid or prohibit
members acting as agents of the state
from following those directives or
regulations that are imposed by
executive order
um recently there was a uh
an opinion done about the bum stock ban
that and our former president
had um
issued an order to direct the atf and
atfe to
ban the possession of bump stocks well
it was upheld in several lower courts
but the sixth circuit in michigan ruled
last month
that uh
it was they were not able to arbitrarily
or unilaterally rewrite their own rule
because they thought it was
unconstitutional it's not their they
said that it is not the role of the
executive branch to dictate to the
public what is right and wrong the
judgments are reserved to the people
through their dilected
duly elected representatives in congress
so i think that uh states not following
uh executive orders at the federal level
which are not intended for them to
follow anyway is not only necessary but
it's a reasonable
um
decision that is sending a strong
message that we will not comply in new
hampshire with arbitrary orders that are
not passed through congress
thank you
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for
his testimony
at this time the chair recognized uh
good afternoon can you hear me okay
yes we can hear and uh
we apologize if we're behind schedule
that's okay
i know the previous bill had people had
lots of a lot to say thank you for
allowing me to testify i'm opposed to
this bill and i would like to tell you
why
and i also want to clarify i'm coming to
you as a member of the public as a
mother as a grandmother and yes i am a
resident of hanover but i hope you will
not disqualify what i have to say
because i come from a very liberal town
um
so here are the points i'd like to make
about this bill and why i'm opposed um i
think some of
i think we need to clarify some of our
um
assumptions behind what we're talking
about
so
i'm clarifying owning a firearm is
absolutely your right
the issue here is not about owning a
firearm it's not about the second
amendment right the issue is gun
violence in this country
so the goal of any federal legislation
or presidential executive order on
firearms is to reduce gun violence
if we only focus on the right to bear
arms then we are not doing anything
about preventing gun violence and the
mass shootings that have recently
sb 154 takes issue with any executive
order on firearms issued by the
president of the united states
yet hb 307 i know that's not an issue at
the moment
hb 307 takes issue with local schools or
municipalities making a decision on
firearms because we're not a home rule
state
so
does this mean that the state of new
hampshire will be the only entity that
can rule on firearms in the granite
state
do we pick and choose who makes the
decision who has the authority to make
the decisions on firearms i for one
my other my final thought is
instead of
having this discussion about gun owners
rights
why can't we just join forces and work
together and find ways to reduce gun
violence i really appreciate your time
all right see no andre the witnesses
excuse me thank you
video it still says senate bill
[Music]
that could be up
to the update so don't
confusion
at this time the chair recognizes dr
mr patience
well that's being worked out the chair
will now recognize aaron
um
alright
just this time the chair now recognize
hi can you hear me
yes we can hear you
great please ignore the moana music
downstairs from the kids
my name is andrew hawkins i'm the
director of gun sense new hampshire a
project of granite state progress i'm
here today to testify in opposition to
senate bill 154 let's be honest this
bill is not about protecting second
amendment rights it's about preserving
the corporate gun lobby's ability to
increase profits off the murder of
american families
mass shootings fill our new cycle each
week and we shake our heads and some of
you have the audacity to offer thoughts
and prayers instead of concrete action
now the biden administration and leaders
in congress are working urgently to save
lives and the response by some new
hampshire politicians is to find ways to
block stop and delay those efforts even
though it will cost lives and even
though we should all be able to agree
that our family shouldn't have to live
in fear of going to the grocery store or
to work or to school or to the movie
theater or to a health clinic or a
bowling alley or walking down the street
in our community or playing in the park
or living in our homes because dangerous
individuals can easily access firearms
and shoot and kill our families
let's sign aside for the moment that
senate bill 154 and the proposed
amendment are likely unconstitutional
that it could cost new hampshire to lose
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
federal grants and aid and it is
completely absurd to block public safety
laws
here are some of the things that this
bill proposes to stop
the biden harris administration
has directed the justice department to
issue a proposed rule to help stop the
proliferation of ghost guns as more
criminals buy kids to assemble firearms
in as little as 30 minutes to commit
crimes that cannot be traced to the
weapon this proposed rule will help stop
the proliferation of these firearms
they will issue a proposed rule to make
clear that devices marketed as a
stabling race like those purchased by
the shooter in the boulder mass shooting
are subject to the national firearms act
they'll publish model red flag
legislation for states that will make it
easier for states to adopt red flag laws
which allow family members of law
enforcement to petition for a court
order temporarily barring people in
crisis from accessing firearms if they
are present
a danger to themselves or others these
are the types of measures that we would
always hear
would have been helpful before a mass
shooting
the justice department will issue an
annual report on firearms trafficking
new hampshire is a net exporter of crime
guns
they're looking at evidence-based
community violence interventions
improving strategies for reducing gun
violence and funding to help with those
community violence interventions
does governor sununu and this
legislative body want to turn down
federal dollars that could benefit new
hampshire from this source or others
mrs hawkins
we did limit testimony to one minute per
person um
a lot of people signed the testimony i
have uh appeared to have not been able
to stay but i am going to ask you if you
can just wrap up your testimonies
members will be permitted to still ask
thank you sb 154 would also jeopardize
public safety in other ways preventing
state work with atf the department of
justice or fbi
a couple of examples here would new
hampshire law enforcement not be
permitted to cooperate with doj
investigations on extremist white
national groups or militias in the state
when firearms are involved creating
further harm for granted staters of
color and others targeted by hate crimes
would it limit the ability to hold
accountable granite staters who
participated in the violent insurrection
in washington d.c
governor sununu famously had to cancel
his public inauguration earlier this
year over fears of armed protesters just
months after an armed militia in another
state hatched a plan to kidnap the
governor of michigan
yes cinema 154 could prevent the state
of new hampshire from
miss august you still have to conclude
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
one of the things you mentioned earlier
in your testimony was the fact that
there are some things about uh this
particular bill um that may not pass
muster from a constitutional
uh uh standpoint i know that's one of
the things i think a lot of people are
interested in is you know does a state
like the state of new hampshire actually
have the power
uh to basically
say
we're not going to do that um if
congress passes a law or the um
i'm miss hawkins your mutations please
don't meet yourself
thank you that just came through uh it's
an excellent question i think that this
um this proposal has a lot of uh
reasons why it would end up in a lawsuit
costing the state of new hampshire
a lot of money and at the same time it
would really prevent our state from
upholding public safety laws that we do
have from the books or accessing federal
grants or participating in really
important
conversations across state and federal
agencies
representing your student follow-up plan
no no follow-up thank you
representative you are recognized for a
question
thank you very much mr chair um thank
you miss rice hawkins for your testimony
um
i'm wondering about um the effective
date
like how would this
how would this impact the the state of
new hampshire
um if it were to
it's a great question about the
enactment date we did notice um so there
we understand there's an amendment and
in the amendment we saw that it removes
the enactment date which leads us to
wonder whether or not
those putting that forward are actually
looking to have
any kind of
retroactive effect on any arrests or
sentences that have already taken place
and we do wonder if it could result in
appeals that would lead to convicted
may i have a follow-up mr chair
representative also you're recognized by
follow-up questions thank you very much
uh miss maurice hawkins um will there
what kind of impact who who will be
impacted by this and
um can you tell me like what would
happen to armed militias in this state
that have
coalesced
thank you very much for asking that
because armed militia activity has been
growing across new hampshire as well as
white supremacist activity it's
something we're very concerned about our
organization has been
raising the alarm on it for over a year
now and you saw that really come to a
head around some of the activities down
in dc with the violent insurrection as
well as governor sununu as i mentioned
having to cancel his public inauguration
earlier this year over fears of armed
protesters
this is a very real situation and a
policy like senate bill 154 could really
limit the ability for us to proactively
address or in the unfortunate
circumstances of activity that happens
hold accountable those bad actors who
are threatening uh granite staters and
and
our public leaders
and then in terms of who this would
effect or impact you know one of the
things that's true about senate bill 154
is that it does cast a really wide net
it would prohibit state and local police
but also judges prosecutors other state
actors
from enforcing administering or
cooperating with any federal law act
rule order regulation if the state of
new hampshire doesn't have
those specific laws in place
i can
i think it would be really beneficial
for this committee to ask um
prosecutors members of law enforcement
the judicial body how they think that
this would impact them both in terms of
the work that they already do
the cooperation they have across state
and federal agencies as well as any
grants that they receive from the
federal level to do the work to keep our
seeing no further hands raised i want to
thank the
one day to win this firefight
[Music]
at this time the chair will recognize
thank you
i'm tracy hon burkett and i'm here on
behalf of myself and as the leader of
the kent street coalition's working
group on gun violence prevention
i'm testifying against sb 154 because
people are dying from gunshots in this
country every single day
it's not just a few it's nearly 40 000
people a year
we see it on the news all the time we're
no longer surprised to learn of mass
shootings these reports are only
slightly less regular than the sports
and the weather reports children today
do not regard being shot at school or
elsewhere as something that probably
won't happen to them now it's true that
new hampshire does better than most
states but more than 150 people died
here by gunshot in 2019 to say nothing
of those who were shot and survived we
can do better if only we choose to
now given congress's inaction in this
area the biden administration has chosen
to do something via executive order a
means of governing that was just fine
with the current new hampshire majority
party until as it says in the bill
january 20th 2021
um
the planned
amendment
um would for example
the
i also want to speak against the
amendment that we know is planned
because it seeks to remove from the
people of new hampshire any and all
protection that may be offered to them
by the federal government which would
mean for some people and in some cases a
matter of life or death it seeks to
divorce the people of new hampshire from
the functions of the united states when
it comes to matters of firearms knives
and related items and just to provide an
example if one of the frequent mass
murders of 2021 were to occur in our
state such that the fbi's assistance was
warranted this amendment would make it
illegal for any new hampshire law
enforcement or other official to
cooperate with them and new hampshire
law enforcement would likely not be able
to cooperate with federal agencies on
investigations of extremist white
nationalist groups or militias in the
state particularly when they are led
there via firearms based incidents and
of course that could have a
disproportionate negative impact on new
hampshire people of color
so just to sum up people want the
overall bloodshed to stop and this bill
is explicit in its intent to protect
firearms but nowhere does it mention any
desire to protect people
and so i would just urge you to vote to
seeing no hands raised
the chairman i recognize
good afternoon mr chair members of the
committee alan rice again with gun
owners of america
um i did submit written testimony
of our support for this bill
when i drafted my written testimony i
was under the mistaken impression that
there was an amendment
from the chair and representative bert
i've been later informed that there's an
amendment just from the chair
i want to state that either amendment is
acceptable to gun owners of america
we're very much in favor of the concept
of not using state and local resources
to enforce federal laws
the federal government they're going to
do what they're going to do they can
pass whatever laws they're going to pass
and there's federal law enforcement
agencies to enforce them
the state
everyone knows new hampshire operates as
a lean state with a lean budget
we pride ourselves on you know new
england frugality um and we clearly
should not be using a state and local
resources to enforce federal gun laws
um we do empathize with some of the
previous speakers we're not in favor of
the violence we're not in favor of the
bloodshed we're not in favor of any of
the things that are going on around the
country at this time
but we disagree
we disagree because if there were to be
such an incident in new hampshire
there's plenty of state crimes that new
hampshire law enforcement could charge a
murderer with
and there's nothing that would prevent
new hampshire law enforcement from
collaborating with fbi or atf
in the case of true criminal activity
this bill doesn't prevent that what it
prevents
is the cooperation by state and local
law enforcement and wholesale gun
confiscation harassment of legitimate
licensed gun dealers harassment of
legitimate uh firearms owners who have
done nothing wrong other than perhaps
assemble the firearm at home
which is something that's been done for
over 200 years in our republic
and rather than go on i'm going to refer
to my written testimony and urged the
committee to adopt either the
uh representative abbas amendment or the
representative abbas burt amendment and
vote uh the amendment and senate bill
154 ought to pass and i will entertain
questions if any representatives are so
inclined
thank you mr wright for your testimony
the chair recognizes representative
panther office for a question
thank you mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question mr
rice could you tell me how many numbers
you have in your organization
we have over 2 million members and
supporters nationwide
in new hampshire new hampshire will be
close to 10 000.
this time the chair recognizes
representative news for a question
[Music]
thank you very much and thank you for
taking my question
um
the biden administration recently
announced a an executive order uh that
would
that would ban ghost guns and i guess my
question to you is is
do you think ghost guns present
an issue
in terms of gun violence and
is the proliferation of ghost guns
something that your organization would
support
guns
guns are not violent
guns are inanimate objects
no more responsible for violence
than the automobile that was driven by
the murderer in charlottesville virginia
and we don't refer to it as automobile
violence
there is no such thing as a ghost gun
guns are not invisible
what i believe you're referring to
representative is firearms that are home
built and home assembled
that is an activity that has gone on
since before the founding of our
republic we endorse the activity we
support the activity we do not agree
with banning the home assembly of
firearms for one's personal use in any
representative you're recognized for any
follow-up questions sure so just just so
we're crystal clear
you have no problem at all with ghost
guns
i have no problem with people home
assembling firearms for their own
representative
representative all children tonight for
thank you very much mr chair
and thank you very much mr rice um for
returning
and taking my question
my question said my question is that
um
you just mentioned that you support the
amendments
i only have
access to one of the amendments
and um
mike i'm curious are you aware in the
amendment that it says that united that
the state of new hampshire
or any public political subdivision of
the state or any person acting under
the color of state county or municipal
law shall be prohibited from using
any personnel or any financial resources
to enforce administer or cooperate with
any law act rule or order or regulation
of the united states government
or executive order of the president so
we
it actually does very specifically state
we would not
be allowed to participate with
the fbi
or the cia or any other federal agency
that were to come to new hampshire to
assist
um
with
questions
so are you did you understand that when
you said you supported this amendment
the amendment that i read let me pull it
back up so i can follow along
talk about laws and rules specifically
uh with respect to firearms
right 19 through 21 are we looking at
the same thing let me um let me pull it
and mr chair with with respect i
understand that this um amendment has
not been introduced yet
but
you've asked
us to let the witness respond to your
question once he is able to review the
materials
yes
um was free
um
just to clarify excuse me mr rice i'm so
sorry um i'm sorry i'm looking for some
clarification from the chair
can i just explained to you
you asked the question to the witness so
i'm going to repeat myself
i want the witness to respond to your
question
if after the business response to your
question if you wish to make an inquiry
of the chair you may do so but i don't
want that to be two conversations
happening at once so please allow the
witness to answer the question you just
previously asked okay thank you very
much so yes mr rice
um
on the abbess amendment
so my question was is that are you
agreeing as your organization
gun owners of america
agreeing with that amendment
yes i think you left out the second half
of that amendment that says with respect
to firearms i'm not going to read the
whole thing we all have a copy
it doesn't say
forbid
cooperation with the federal government
on things other than firearms this is
very narrow with respect to firearms and
yes i stand by what i said a moment ago
we support the amendment offered by
representative abbas
okay may follow up mr chair yes and
representative if you are referring to
an amendment it may be helpful to
reference
uh not just the sponsors but perhaps the
amendment number so just some members of
the public
or
members of the committee are clear on
which amendment you're referring to
uh yes um my apologies so sorry uh the
amendment
was just referring to is amendment one
two two zero h
um dated 405. so
that was the amendment that we were just
referring to
and um so my follow-up question to mr
rice
um
if your concern
is around violence as you have testified
do you think we should pass any laws
that around who could access firearms
what type of firearms or both
no i think we should repeal the laws
that prevent people from easily
i'm sorry i it said i was muted can you
hear me now
we can i'm i'm sorry um i said i think
we should do the contrary we should uh
repeal the laws that make it difficult
inconvenient and expensive for
law-abiding people to access
self-defense firearms i think people
have an absolute right to defend
themselves
and if you look at new hampshire and
maine
with our
very
gun laws that allow people to actually
defend themselves in comparison to
places like new york and chicago where
that right is encumbered i think you'll
find that it's much safer up here
representative
representative bradley you are
recognized for every question
thank you chairman
um so mr rice so you're seeing that
you're happy with anybody owning a gun
anyone and everybody to protect
themselves
i don't think i said that representative
i said i am happy and comfortable with
law-abiding citizens owning firearms for
legitimate self-defense or any other
reason that they see fit as guaranteed
by the second amendment
president you're recognized for a
follow-up question
thank you so mr ice how would we ensure
their law abiding citizens
once they break the law we have police
who are very capable of investigating
arresting and prosecuting those law
breakers but until they break the law
they have the same constitutional rights
as everybody else and we should not
are there any members of the public
who wish to testify that are in
attendance that have not testified
testified already
just a reminder testimony is limited to
one minute
thank you thank you chairman
for the record j.r hole dunbarton new
hampshire um also of the new hampshire
board of sorry new hampshire firearms
coalition board of directors we are in
support of sb 154 but we would ask for
an amendment and we would ask for an
amendment that goes further than just
executive orders executive orders are
only the tip of the iceberg
and what happened when biden wrote the
executive orders he directed the atf to
start implementing rules
and the bigger issue at hand is much
broader than just the particular
emergency orders or executive orders by
the president
we would ask that you would adopt an
amendment that addresses both or
addresses all of the following
congressional actions
executive orders and atf rules and that
there be penalties for
local and state officials who choose to
follow federal law
over state law when it comes or federal
rules over over state law when it comes
to enforcement of these policies
as one of the former members who
testified said the federal government
has employees that can can enforce these
laws
but we shouldn't be using our state
resources that way
so i will ask that you adopt a stronger
amendment than what was passed out of
seeing no hands raised the witnesses
excused
is any members of the type of wish to
testify that have not testified already
we'll be in recess for
laura i don't think anybody is answering
questions
um because i can't see the room
something's over there
yeah i don't know i think that i'm
wondering if they put that up since
we're in recess i guess
okay
i want to thank you again for helping me
ready
i'm always happy happy to help you when
you need a chair or need to get unmuted
well we're being recorded
so
god
uh
foreign
do
hey
[Music]
members at home hear us
yeah i can't i have a question for the
chair
you may ask the question
mr i'm just curious why there was a
paper put over the uh camera during the
recess
right
i don't know why
okay i just thought it was inappropriate
for us to be uh
visually hampered from the
room
or any formal session and that's it we
actually have business to address and i
prefer to address the business
he's raising a point
all right i respect the representative
for raising it and he's entitled to do
[Music]
there is no real need to i guess
blocking camera
so i think so
well that's that's the decision
well they're all blocked
that's all right
excuse me we now open the executive
session
on senate bill 154
an act prohibiting the state from
enforcing a presidential executive order
that restricts or regulates the rights
of the people to keep and bear ours
at this time the chair will recognize
representative welch to make a motion
about the task and offer an amendment
all right i make the notion of the house
bill 154
that that motion has been separated by
and to offer an amendment
at this time he's now offered the
amendment that was also seconded by
representative
actually representative walls
so
the author passes was it was
sec now emotions the amendment's being
offered
from the bus do you wish to discuss the
amendment
however this has the severability for it
which is an important part of it because
if any part of the
this uh
legislation
it's time to chair now open the question
uh thank you mr chair uh i'm going to
oppose the amendment and uh and oppose
the bill
uh i don't think that the amendment
helps to bill uh one iota
um
this is uh
uh what's very very likely uh
an unconstitutional uh abrogation of
federal government that we also elect uh
we just don't elect a government here in
new hampshire we elect a federal
government as well
uh and i'm also looking at uh some of
the orders
that uh
you know that the uh that the
administration is actually uh looking at
getting passed uh and and frankly
uh ghost guns are an increasing problem
uh the fact that they're untraceable
um uh really puts law enforcement over
the barrel when it comes to
trying to associate uh these guns with
people who who've committed crimes
um these are guns that also empower
people that we don't necessarily want
empowered as a society
like militias and white supremacist
groups um who may not want to who
uh who may have some members who uh may
not actually be able to walk into a gun
store uh and to buy their weapons
legally so uh the issue is i i think
that
in new hampshire
anybody who wants to buy a gun legally
uh
can buy a gun
it it's not an issue
uh and i think
what this bill would do is it would
dramatically weaken the ability
of us to
uh
keep guns out of the hands you know of
people who simply uh shouldn't have them
and who could endanger public safety
and i do think that part of our role as
legislators
isn't just always taking an absolute
absolutist viewpoint of whatever
happens to be uh happens to be in the
bill of rights i think we also need to
take a look at the fact that we have a
very real obligation
uh to protect public safety and and i
think that with the executive order on
ghost guns that's something that the
biden administration has taken response
has essentially um
uh
taken responsibility to uh you know to
to make sure we have that sort of
protection
so
the
the bottom line is i i i don't think uh
that passing this bill uh would be a
tremendously wise thing and i also think
it would be uh an absolutely terrible
precedent uh for us to set
uh what's next
guns what's next income taxes uh we
don't have income taxes in new hampshire
you know how dare the federal government
uh you know uh try to impose in income
taxes on people who've never voted for a
state income tax you know where does it
stop
um and i think where it needs to stop is
thank you
represent me if i may just require
progression what about
this
amendment do you find to be
unconstitutional
but you still do you still muted mr
chairman i would actually like to hear
from people who are actually uh
some experts in constitutional law as
opposed to people who are experts on
selling guns uh when it comes to uh to
bills like this
um
i do think that uh
that uh
that there are
uh
that they're
i think that to the the the tenth
amendment uh i believe uh is uh uh is
the amendment that uh that
essentially
um
uh prohibits states or or that that puts
guidelines around uh uh what states can
do uh in terms of uh
of dealing with the the
power forcing federal laws
um
and i uh you know i i just think again
that this is uh it's a it's a it's a bad
precedent uh and it puts us in a
in a in a tough position as a state and
and bottom line is when it comes to
something like ghost guns uh if these
actually do become a problem in new
hampshire how do we
what do we do
you know uh
it's it's an un it's an unnecessary bill
uh at a bad time uh and i don't think we
need
it representative
representative defender office you were
i i just imperious to the fact
of we must interfere with any
can anybody answer that
he would pretend
it would it would matter on the
specific type of brand that you would be
what second question
would it interfere anyway
with this money that's coming in
from
the culvert
i'm not i'm not aware of having any
success restrictions
previously mentioned
article 10 he alluded to it as if if the
federal government had the right
to tell the
states what to do
let me immediately it's fairly short it
says the power is not delegated in the
united states by the constitution
or prohibited by the states
are reserved to the states respectively
or to their people
this is sort of limiting to the federal
government we tend to believe that
if they give us money or if uh you know
they smile right
that they have a right
to governors
and they have a right to govern us up to
a point so
you got to read the right part of the
constitution and the real constitution
this time the chair recognizes uh
representative welch uh it's kind of a
executive artist
what is that in the consciousness
it's the executive branch
making laws
i don't think there's anything wrong
with
the chair recognizes representative
oshawa
thank you mr chair
um so
um
i do want to point out that
first of all the federal government
absolutely has the right to place
conditions on any federal funds um so
there is a distinct possibility that
were this kind this amendment or even
the original bill to pass
um yeah we could be looking at
um
at a you know uh
a quid pro quo on getting federal funds
particularly if we're not going to abide
by
um executive orders um
and i want to remind the committee that
several states
um passed tried to pass nullification
laws like this under president obama and
those were ruled unconstitutional this
amendment
and the underlying bill um will not
pass muster they are they will not pass
a constitutional
um
challenge
and um
it's a it's a
it's a lawsuit just
in the waiting i don't know why we would
specifically want to do that
um and and also
we have we know
we are aware
that there are groups that call
themselves militia
and have shown up
in various places
around our around the state at different
um spaces i've seen them at you know at
the
at the aapi
support rally that i was at with
representative manjuputi
and um
should they decide to take
violent action
yeah the fbi would want to come here to
new hampshire and this amendment and the
underlying bill
would
exclude and preclude
uh local law enforcement and the state
police
from cooperating and there would be two
different investigations going on if
there were there would be this would
this would
cut us out of cooperation
so um i don't think that's a very good
idea
at all
to cut us out of cooperating with our
thank you representative representative
you mentioned that a case was
a rule bank
it feels similar to senate bill 154 has
unconstitutional do you have the case
i'm sorry was that a question for me i
mentioned that it was
a similar laws of
which senator 154
have been ruled unconstitutional
i'm asking if you have the title of the
case that builds
a lot similar to
you i don't need the full-size
so um there was a nullification case
brought against um
the
and there
and i if you want i will put together a
list for you but there was arkansas
tried to do a nullification case um for
nullifying gun restrictions
so i mean i can i can put together more
thank you
representative where may you're
recognized
mr chair
um
i've heard arguments before
looking for
a uh a problem
i i don't see how it just feels solving
any problem that uh exists
uh there's a possibility of a problem in
the future but there certainly isn't a
problem at the moment
uh and i wanna
add one more thing and that is
uh
and this may be questionable
that
um
federal law
is
our local and state government law
enforcement
are not authorized to
enforce federal law
only federal agents are
so
i don't understand why we need this bill
or the amendment to the bill
so
[Music]
if the federal law and the state law are
consistent it's not precluding the
state government from working together
right so
this requires there to be any federal
law that will be passed
if
uh congress would have passed a bill to
confiscate all the firearms of everybody
who owns them that would be quite
inconsistent
i can't imagine anybody going along with
that
but it doesn't it people it's also
clarified
if you violate federal law that it's
still a crime you're just violating
federal law
and there is i mean i can recall
precedence in his own committee passage
was doing that the
last term was hb 481
both of the recreational marijuana a
recreational candidate and in that bill
it expressly stated that local law
enforcement
officials will not cooperate with
federal officers and enforcing
uh
federal
cannabis laws so
we have that they may pass in this
committee of passing the house class
term it didn't become wrong
so it has been done and all is the same
is that the state
is not going to enforce laws that are
inconsistent the federal laws are
executive orders that are inconsistent
with the statements
and if there is a new law that were to
come out i would believe it would be
something the state should consider
that's for saying the circumstances
congress would take large capacity
magazines and put a ban on them
everybody who's got those
the value of those goes up 10 times
well i didn't realize that before
it's
just i understand too with something
that would happen it also can affect the
transfer even the value may go up but
immediately speaking the restriction
will transfer from these problems
represent a board
thank you chair
um i will point out to you that uh
federal law
where he
says that firearms are not allowed on
school property unless you are carrying
a concealed uh
permit
in the state of new hampshire
say that school boards cannot
regulate
uh firearms on school property so
the only way that school boards can
really enforce
a federal law about firearms is to call
but it also could be addressed or
enforced if the state were to pass a law
if
that's something that the state can put
into consideration
representative uh klein knight you're
recognized
thank you so much i'm i'm really
troubled by a lot of this testimony
today because
on one hand um
i was informed and i got emails that
made me really think you know um
one of them representative burke replied
to about um an asian-american woman that
doesn't feel safe right now and
uh you know wants to go out and just be
able to purchase a gun
um and i
felt really
uh sympathetic with her um
because i err on the side of the victim
and
that's how both these bills were
represented yet
the biggest supporters
made me feel like
victims
don't matter and that
it's their responsibility to protect
themselves and we're like we should just
go ahead and fail them is is kind of
like the the want over having a second
or third or fifth gun
outweighed the need to protect the
domestic violence dispute really
troubled me
and then when the uh coalition for
victims and sexual violence testified
against the bill that really
brought my okay are we listening to them
and then
i'm saying we're on one senate 154 not
141. it's okay i'm tying them all
together i'll get there and then
uh
speak hearing testimony about
you know an elected official
uh say we shouldn't trust the biden
administration
uh because maybe they could take away
our guns and all you know
you know everybody's really fearful here
but in the same breath we hear oh you
know go ahead and let the federal
government take care of this
and with this bill in particular with
representative bordenay just brought up
is we could be potentially losing
hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars in school federal funding
because we haven't done our homework and
is the want for
another gun that more important than
victims school children and all this
other stuff that we haven't
really
researched enough
and it comes down to us the buck stops
here what is our responsibility
and um i just find it really
hypocritical of
of the argument to be don't trust
the federal government but then let's
shirk our own state responsibilities
because it's their responsibility to
take care of us i'm very confused and i
don't think that argument should be
you know looked at both ways when it
just suits us
we have a responsibility
i think to public safety
i i i appreciate the comments and that i
understand what you're saying
all right representative barry you're
recognized to speak on the amendment
well i did find the case it's prince
p-r-i-n-t-z
prince i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing
that right versus united states 5-2-1
us-898
specifically allows states to not
enforce federal governments
it was brought to the supreme court and
they found in our favor
you know because they were trying to
enforce the brady act and
the supreme court said that that is not
i'm in support of this bill
and
i'm glad that representative knight
brought up that lady that emailed me
because i forgot you know i remembered
this morning about it i was thinking
about it but then i forgot over the day
but i want her right
to be able if she chooses to purchase a
nun to protect herself in this state or
anywhere else in the united states i
think it's her right
and
this bill this amendment will
allow that to happen
so there is supreme court
decisions on this
i believe this will not be challenged or
it will be challenged but it will be
thrown out
so as this passes i think it's a great
thing
you know we live with some
i think in new hampshire sanctuary uh
cities
and
i guess that's okay but
this isn't for some reason so i guess
i'm kind of lost there but i just want
to point out that we do have sanctuaries
you're not recognizing the speech
you're out of order
now the bill did die on the house i
didn't die it was retained on the house
floor down in bedford and uh we are
going to work on that over the summer
to see how we can address that issue
this bill is spot on it's a good bill i
support it and i hope you guys do too
thank you're indicating that some cities
are not enforcing federal laws
that is correct
representative welch there are some
cities that say mountain forces
are lost i understand
that and they i can appreciate that
that's similar to the knowledge i made
with with the cannabis laws yes
even
even therapeutic candidates which i i
support and i believe there's a lot of
positives
and we just
at the tip of the iceberg with the
benefits of therapy to cannabis
but that's still against federal law
and you know here in new hampshire
yes right tip the iceberg we're not
we're permitting that that happened that
is
in violation of federal law and
we're just the state's policies we're
just not going to enforce that federal
you know we're not going to enforce that
the state if the federal government came
in and
decided out of nowhere and they haven't
may i just have one you know three
seconds let me just i appreciate that uh
mr chairman uh
over the years my good friend you know
representative welch and i you know
we've been together in this committee
for a long time and we
you know we have voted
to decrim marijuana against federal
wishes
and i tell everybody
i've never touched the stuff you do what
you want none of my business what you do
behind closed doors
but i'm telling you that if you do it it
is still against the federal laws
and people like to still go forward with
this types of legislation even though
it's against the federal law and they're
happy to
buy their marijuana or their gummy bears
or whatever they're buying with the um
marijuana in it to help them you know if
they got a medical card or even not a
medical parent and i know some of them
are still buying guns
well
there's two differences in just
when they come to this recreational
candidates the supreme court actually
did rule on that and wrote a lot of the
preemption laws that the
feds can come in and
actually
make the arrest of them yes so that's
actually been decided by the supreme
court where we're in the opposite here
with firearms
the other way around but again we're
just not enforcing the law we're not
getting we're not encouraging or
violating anybody that would absolutely
work right
that would be a crime yes thank you mr
chairman representative you're
recognized
thank you mr i kind of have a question
for the chair um is it my understanding
that when we're doing this it's uh it's
not a debate back and forth that we just
make our points and
uh we move on and you recognize the next
person
so
although
you know mason's has two different
references i didn't bring the book with
me today but what
even when you recognize someone to speak
you're not supposed to recognize another
person to speak until everyone's had an
opportunity to speak however it also
encourages the healthy uh flow of
discussion so provided people aren't
yelling over each other and talking over
each other and cutting each other off
and it's extremely difficult if
especially because with
the digital hearing zoom there's always
a
half a second or a second delay that you
can have three people yelling over each
other so i wouldn't consider people
yelling with each other to be
healthy back and forth but if two
members are talking about before i mean
representative i asked him a question he
responded to it
and now i consider that to be a healthy
back and forth and
it's it's i believe it's within the
discretion that you have to promote that
it's not to exploit anyone from the
conversation but as long as people
members don't stop interrupting each
other and yelling over each other
uh i would hope that would be the
practice and we've been really we could
do that on every executive session that
would really be the preference of the
chair
okay thank you
representing many recognized for
parliament report
yeah my inquiry would be would it be
better in order to promote the
communication that you were talking
about i realize you don't have to
recognize yourself for a question to
someone else
that we if we wanted to question
somebody to to run that question through
if you wish to ask a question of a
member you most certainly may raise your
hand to ask a question to that member
i'm just saying if there is a help
you are on the committee and served with
me last term and there was a different
chair and that i would say that your i
respect very much an excellent job of
letting the members have healthy
conversations
even when we were very far apart on
agreeing on on topics
uh i don't i don't recall that you're
having to
gamble a member a single time last last
term
like in far i mean i didn't have perfect
attendance so many capital i wasn't here
but
uh
it can be done both ways and i think if
as long as we're not yelling over each
other or talking with each other
and conducting ourselves professionally
and maintaining the quorum that's the
way to go
i appreciate your response and and
you're correct about the way we had
conversations when everybody was there
and everybody was in person
but this term we've had more of a
emphasis on parliamentary procedures in
order to keep order because some people
are not there and that's the only
motivation behind my question to see
representative
thank you mr chair so i wanted to dial
back to a statement that i made earlier
about um i i believe that
this amendment and the underlying bill
would set new hampshire up for very
lengthy and very expensive lawsuits and
i'm going to use an example that is
happening right now
so in arkansas
arkansas governor asa hutchinson
and said that the measure would
jeopardize law enforcement and the
public
and he his work his
veto message was the partnership between
state and federal law enforcement
officers is essential for the safety of
arkansas citizens this bill will break
that partnership and put the safety of
arkansas at risk and i believe that that
applies to new hampshire as well
so we all know that the republican
led legislature
that wants to
pass this
overrode his veto and now it goes to
court so we would be looking at very
similar if you know this were to pass we
would get embroiled in um lawsuits very
similar to that and i find it um
troubling
that
this this amendment and this underlying
bill this
this measure to
um
try to nullify the federal government's
authority
uh is b is happening
in a dozen other states you know this
isn't this isn't um original it's not
new
um and it's being presented in alabama
arkansas which you know is now beyond
this and into the lawsuit stage it's in
nebraska oklahoma it's in south carolina
wyoming north dakota tennessee west
virginia
iowa
um and in texas the texas governor is
calling for their state to become a
second second
amendment sanctuary so um this in in
arizona they're looking to pass
um pass a bill very similar to this too
what is the
why
why is there um a sudden
interest
in um wanting to pass these bills that
are absolutely going to embroil us in
litigation
um and
potentially put our citizens in danger
and and absolutely drive a wedge
into the cooperation that should be
happening between
our local law enforcement and state
police
and federal officials if there were to
be
um a tragedy
so
what does this what does this what
problem does this solve
because it seems like it just makes more
problems
a tragedy
in you know some type of gun violence
that's already against state law and i
hope
that
state county municipal federal officers
even if it's interstate would all work
together
i'm not aware of any statement that that
would be legal and
going back to the discussion
representative part and representative
welch and i we're kind of having
his other laws that federal laws that
it becomes a policy that will not be
enforced whether it's
immigration whether it's on some of the
federal uh laws related to controlled
substances so
it's it's been done before and
but that's not what we're talking about
that's not germane to this bill we're
talking about specifically this bill
specifically
speaks of firearms ammunition magazines
ammunition feeding devices firearm
components firearm supplies or knives
so um you know has a very very narrow
scope
and you know
so that's that's in in both of these in
the underlying and the amendment super
narrow i can clarify that i can clarify
the analogy the analogy is that any
federal firearm regulations and compared
to any federal immigration regulations
or any federal uh
regulations of laws related to control
services we're comparing those in power
that the state
chooses to adopt them uh follow them or
enforce them or not that's the analogy
we're not saying that they're the exact
same subject
the philosophy of not
uh enforcing the federal law the state
level is something that's been done
before in other areas of law unrelated
representative hopper are you recognized
yeah thank you mr chair and kind of
it goes backwards but during the uh
the uh
idiots down in dc
objection excuse me mr chair i i am
strongly about to miss character and i'm
also i'm trying to reach for the gavel
represent hawker yes as a member of the
committee let's not refer to anyone
as an idiot please we
it's not it's not appropriate uh it's
not it's not
it's not difficult
1800s called the future of slave act and
it was in massachusetts the state and
the local people refused to abide
by the egypt slave act because it was
against people's primary
constitutional rights against their
liberty
so
protecting people's liberty in new
hampshire is consistent with states
see
no
yeah i would just remind everybody as a
courtesy that if you are participating
remotely and
your camera's not on once the matter is
put to question you will not be
research
the matter will now be put to question
if your support of adopting
zero zero 2021-1200
please say hey if you are opposed please
say nay the clerk will not call the
world
yes
representative
representative wallace yes
testament yes
representative
yay
representative pratt yes
[Music]
yay
no
representative newman
representative
no
uh representative um
representative knight
no
representative bradley
and chairman abbas
[Music]
a vote of 11 days and
10 days
it's going to be 11 days and 10 days the
has been seconded by representative
wallace
the understanding that the
amendment that we adopted for the most
part
replaced our rewrote the
originally senate bill 154
all right if there's any further
discussion i will recognize any members
same seeing no hands raised uh the
matter will now be quick depression the
motion is taught to pass as amended if
you are in support please say
yay if you are opposed please say nay
yes representative testament yes
representative true yes
representative pratt yes
representative marshton yay
representative
yes
says no
representative pantomics
no
represent from her
from senator goodnight
no
representative news no
representative newman
no
representative bolton
representative archer
no
representative fine knight
representative bradley
no
i heard of 11 years and 10 days the
emotion of authentas
as amended
[Music]
yes
would be a
seminar
yes
thank you mr chairman will there be a
minority report
yes
this time we will now close the
executive session on senate bill
154.
for the members in the room uh i was
going to open the executive session on
senate bill 110
one involved uh
locking an animal inside of a vehicle
does the members all have a copy that
this time we're going to open the
brought to my attention that
representative
newman which would like to be recognized
is there a second to that motion
second
that the motion got any speed the
legislative uh second by representative
board name
or john do you wish to speak to your
motion
um
i make that motion because i think that
the uh there are several problems with
the bill the way it's written um
even though it has good intentions and
it came from a 17 year old student i i
believe some of the testimony that we
had
that the there's i see problems with the
deputizing of people to take that action
based on some of the testimony we had
from
police officers um it's difficult
to determine extreme temperatures and
even uh
i think one of our committee members who
enforce these types of laws made
comments about um
how difficult it is for a trained law
enforcement officer to make those kind
of decisions
and so
and getting the witness and being
able to get information from somebody to
be a witness and and all of that
just
make makes this a lot uh one that would
be very very difficult to enforce and
perhaps put people at uh
in like a
a situation where they are liable for
damages and stuff like that because of
um not meeting all the requirements that
are in the in the proposed law
thank you representative
i agree that
senator 110 is was
very well intended that
raises the concern of the animals being
left in
inside rock inside vehicles when there's
extreme temperatures whether that's hot
or cold
my concern was just again despite how
well intended it is
the intent was the bill it's
if someone is breaking the car even if
the deputies are doing themselves
because they're authorized by
police to do so it could
turn into a pretty chaotic situation if
the owner vehicle
did come outside while you were doing
that despite your justification and
being justified just seeing that that
situation
being turning into a misunderstanding
it's a concern that i have that as we
would obviously right now if you did
call the police and some of that
happened the police
would authorize you to break the window
uh you could actually do something you
would be i mean
you'd be immune from some traffic
because you would have it in traffic
defense not necessarily
but
it's just
hopefully this situation comes up before
the police can get you fast enough to
save the animal and
seeing uh seeing no further hands raised
the matter will now be put to question
the promotion is
inexpensive legislate if you are in
support
please say yay
sorry
representative
yes representative testament yes
representative true
representative pratt yes
senator marshton
yay
representative
yes
representative news
no
representative newman
yes
representative
muted
maybe she might be frozen just today
it just allowed me to unmute thank you
no
representative playing night
chair goes yes
[Music]
17-4
representative nimmy will you be
preparing the majority report
yes
[Music]
okay if someone wishes to prepare
minority reports please
news
this time we will now close the
we're not going to execute any of any
other bills today
in regards to senate bill 122 and senate
bill 92 which we heard
last week
again if there is any amendments that
anyone wishes to make on any of those
bills you're only allowed it has to be a
positive motion and you only can adopt a
single amendment so
if there's a
provision
of
one section even if it's unrelated prior
section
[Music]
yes yeah so i'm just trying to explain
it but if there is anyone that has any
ideas or
thoughts on any amendments any of those
bills
oh yes um
i know that there are seven parts of
this bill uh three of them are new
topics as far as i'm aware of
uh
uh making great great grandparents uh
part of the guardian chain
um
yes
uh
making a creating a council on autism
disorders
and hold on hold on so the public
understands where representative
boarding is referring to senate bill
122.
yes
and increasing the penalties i think
increasing ponies for harm in a service
animal um those are the new areas in
this bill the other bill parts are all
uh bills that the house has already
passed
so i'm wondering if we want to
reduce the bill to the
new
uh parts of the
i
i support any bill house bill that
passed in this body uh especially out of
this committee i want to sound too
biased
that can pass on on its own as a stand
alone
i would prefer that to pass rather than
mix it in with an ominous bill
there's certain
i don't want someone to vote against the
bill because of one section
and you have three sections that are
completely unrelated so i would
certainly encourage that and then the
optics you only want to pass
the same build twice
so they both get signs of loss whatever
left side second to
senate bill 40 which we have
that's mirrored of hd 45 that 45 is
passed so i'm just monitoring
i've been just checking to see check the
docking and what the set has been doing
with those
so
by our next hearing aid we might have a
better
mr chair i think that the raising the
felony for harming a service dog is
probably uh the most uh
something we really didn't debate very
much
so
i'm willing to offer an amendment for
the bill that offers the uh
great grandparents as part of the
guardian train
and
the
council on
make that the bill
take out the other uh parts that we've
it's as despicable as it is to abuse a
service dog it's still animal abuse
it's
my understanding what that section does
is just create a separate classification
if the dog is a service dog
it's
still falling in the cruelty nonetheless
so
if that part were taken out it's not
it's enhancing the penalty for uh herme
harming a service dog
um i'm not quite willing to go to a a
felony for that
the way it was written
is that and
also independent
the animal is able to continue being a
you know you and i are firefighters
so
and then
if i offer this amendment when are we
going to have an exact session so i can
well
next wednesday we we will not be meeting
next next week we will be meeting
[Music]
on on i believe monday the 10th
all right thank you
so that's that's when you want to try to
make sure you have any
amendments prepared
if uh just give me a moment with senate
bill warnings
you say monday the 10th yeah thank you
uh mr chair i will send you uh a copy of
the amendment uh when it's when it's
written
representative while we're having a very
healthy conversation
with senate bill
remember
that has to do with allowing a person
charged with driving or operating the
influence of drugs or liquor to register
for the impaired driving education
program
conversation
[Music]
is there any concerns that you have with
the very first section
[Music]
which involves
the impediment but i think that we've
already handled driving under the
influence of drugs uh earlier bill
yes but that that was different what
this has to do is if normally if you are
convicted you would that's as part of
the conviction you take
the impaired driving education program
all this allows you to do is not if
while your
charges are pending you can still
actually enroll in the program
you don't actually have to
there can be a scenario where you are
found guilty or excuse me not guilty
but still have taken the
program
and that this would be what it is but it
doesn't allow someone to finish up their
wrap up their probation faster
if they can get ahead of things
i assume that that wouldn't imply any
guilt on behalf of the person doing that
but i'm not you have any problem with
that provision
during the hearing on that bill we did
not hear anybody testify towards that
part of the bill at all
anyone else second thoughts i i
personally i think it's actually it's if
someone first of all someone wants to
attend say that type of program
regardless of the outcome of their case
i'm sure it doesn't hurt i can tell you
that people are found not guilty
this means that the government or the
state cannot meet that burden of proof
sometimes
doesn't mean that person didn't
necessarily get me wrong so it doesn't
hurt to happen first to take the course
if they voluntarily voluntarily chose to
do so by their conviction normally you
have to have the
disposition of the case show that
paperwork you enroll
i don't want to mention any names but i
have heard people say
that uh
they object to a
bunch of
unrelated bills
being
thrown together
and crossed our way
as
has totally said
i don't believe section one was
discussed at all
and that's why this person i was talking
to objects to these
multi unrelated bills being grouped
together
is because every bill doesn't get an
error
so so that one gotta hear it i just said
you know what he was there
so all i'm saying is these are all
yeah maybe maybe pick 12 right
all i'm saying is
i think there are people who will vote
against
this
and i appreciate that and that's what i
will say is hypothetically if i was i
really enjoyed that provision i wouldn't
let i wouldn't
i guess take it out gets taken out i put
all this file
until next next year creating the same
policy
and this would be fortunate to have the
enemy testify about the bill and
all that in here again but you know it
would
it could save us some time if it's a
policy that we all would
in this committee support
refiling something that's right before
us i'm just throwing up there i don't
think i give you the same 122 is not
nearly as complicated
but you're but you're right that
putting the unrelated bills together is
a
practice that i understand some people
representative hopper
yeah
one building was basically three
separate bills all stacked together
everybody
called in and talked about one section
the other two sections which should be
two separate bills
if those were separate
i think people only the public would
have known about them
and maybe chimed in on them or wanted to
chime and knock on them
but because they're pumped together
you're denying the public access to
speak on specific pieces of legislation
so to me i'm not voting for anything
in a clump that's because i think we're
not doing the people's business the way
it was intended but secondarily you know
somebody wants to take out a section
amended so there's only a section if i'm
in favor of it i'll vote for that i'm
not voting yes on these uh cumulative
over um
if this continues
eventually the
criminal justice or the judiciary and
the senate can just send us over 80
bills in one stack and say hey go up or
down
i think it's a bad precedent and we have
a
complicated opportunity and obligation
to start it
yeah all right i i understand so
representative you've heard some of the
comments
some people on the committee
uh those comments aside if you you
prepare an amendment
but it is the desire of some members
that you pick whatever part that you
like the best
if you you can always have more than one
amendment prepared i believe versus
that today we had more than one
amendment so
you can try your luck with two parts and
see how that works
very good
and
i'll leave it i'll leave it to you to uh
have that prepared
mr chair
what's that newman
yeah i just didn't hear what i i believe
i heard representative bordenay talk
about an amendment and it had to do with
the service animals and the increasing
of the penalty
was that correct that he was going to
prepare amendment for that
i basically said that there are three
new parts
of uh in this in this um
122.
uh two of them are non-controversial
uh
the guardianship by great grandparents
and the council for autism disorders
those would be
the amendments that amendment i would
offer for the bill i would not bring in
the
increased penalty for harming a service
job because we didn't really have a very
uh
good discussion on that particular part
of the bill
and but also not uh include part one it
has to do with
driving on your influence and education
because we did not hear any testimony on
is that clear yeah thank you for that
clarification
um
i i have a i have a problem with the
increase of penalty it looks like two
steps up to
making felony for both and
um i i love animals but felony
convictions are a big deal
i agree i think that that deserves to be
a bill by itself
i didn't understand the chair
you had hp 338 that i mean that if he
was seen on the dog
right
nice
i'll look at that you guys all
knocking down that day you wouldn't let
we can wrap up our representative
with our question
yes mr chair don't we have to vote those
other bills down
to accept that amendment
yeah yeah they're just we're just we're
kind of having another i don't know what
you want to call it i was just
suggesting that
people want to
prepare amendments but they would have
to willingly adopt one just reminding
everyone
apple's ready but if if you have
something about one paragraph or one
sentence you want to change and you know
something else is going forward
you may want to
work together and
we're only going to adopt one so it
would make sense
if we have some time we're not meeting
otherwise
i